all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontus and ty guy
travis on that thursday evening campfire
that we love so much let's start with e
how we doing sir what's going on doing
good been busy just you know making
different videos working on content i've
been driving around mexico a little bit
so that's actually been a lot of fun
yeah yeah forza is definitely forza is a
lot of fun like all the hype that you
hear
it's
it's a really fun racing game
and i'm enjoying like the exploration
like the cars and stuff because i
haven't really dove into a racing game
in a long time but there's half of me
that just wants motorsport too
and the main hardcore well
it's a balance because like i like the
fun the exploration kind of going around
like that type of stuff you get a whole
lot of variety
uh but on the other side
basically it's like when you go to do a
track and say i was doing one or i
needed to i had to drive the super
around this town and like scout out the
map which if you guys have done it you
might have and you need to do it in a
certain time but it's not like hey i'm
gonna go to laguna seca and i already
it's like i know the track i know the
turns i'm kind of getting a feel for it
and like really getting that mastery is
a little different because it doesn't
quite feel like a track
so some of that stuff always feels and
it just makes me kind of want both which
actually might work well that gt7 is
coming earlier next year to kind of give
the exploration and forza gt7 still has
to try and do it right which they
haven't done in a while to me so i will
be curious but if it is like
very track specific and they can kind of
get some features right paired with this
one it's kind of a nice balance of both
because it was like motorsport and gt7 i
don't think gt7 would hit as well but if
it's exploration a little more fun and
the gt7 next year i think that actually
might probably do them both well but
verizon five is
very fun travis what have you been up to
man besides working your tail off i'm
sure as usual
yeah so i uh
this week of my preview for uh farming
simulator 22 went live saw that
which yeah i spent a couple days playing
that so uh you can you can see that on
ign and then um i also have been playing
forza horizon 5. i did my first
assignment for the ign wiki team yeah i
had to uh
i had to um document every single xp and
fast travel board on map
before the game came out so i was like
driving around and getting all the
boards is already enough work but when
you have to stop and take a photo and
then go to a interactive map on ign's
website and drop a pin and then attach
it to a page and all that stuff
it's like it slows it down it takes like
five minutes per board so it's like
that's just about signing them and
getting 250 of them right all the boards
yeah 250 of them so it's done if you go
to ign's uh wiki you can see the map i
saw it fully complete it's got
everything i wanted
yeah
you can use that as your guide and uh
and i personally so i i my experience
playing this game now is very weird
because i got every single board before
i did anything including doing any
races just like drove around everything
yeah how did you get that i got every
single board and then after i was done i
was like all right now time to start
playing the game at all well i guess you
don't need exploration for the barns
it's just the boards are all on the map
so like a minute like the map and mini
map the barns are on the map too the
barns eventually get there but like some
of them unlock as you go but yeah right
so yeah man that's that's a lot
i completely did that and then yesterday
i actually started playing the game for
the first time after having gotten
sports
and uh i beat it already
jesus
yeah i'm moving on i'm on to other games
now
this man this man has no time this man
has no time he's got to move on to
bigger and better things
yeah thank you yeah so i'm done man i'm
uh i'm i'm uh
i'm now moving back on to some of my
backlog games i'm also playing uh san
andreas again because the grand theft
auto yeah
so had to boot up and see how my grove
street was keeping um so i was doing
that um but yeah i i continue my quest
to uh to beat every every game this year
that's my
my super objective in those final months
that is insane
what about you sir
yeah
um it's been finally got the disco shout
out to the it is like a fire
truck convoy going by me i apologize um
yeah i finally got a disco done disco
elysium was done
that was so much fun i loved it
yeah started up forza um got a shout out
all dj the crew playing that game in the
convoy is a completely different
experience like it was
so much fun and then everybody splitting
into teams and then like we have we're
racing as a team versus like oh it's so
much fun so we're doing that and uh
shout out to dj you shout out to the
eliminator mode that to me was like
i played one yeah everyone's telling me
about i haven't played it yet everyone's
telling me about it i was like we were
doing like dirt racing
street racing stuff i did my first like
goliath one as a team that one was oh
cool like that i want i gotta achieve me
i got a rare achievement for that i was
very very pleased with myself but um
yeah
yeah other than that i've been doing
that and then um slowly i will get into
it with the dusty stuff slowly peeking
because you know i'm still on my destiny
hiatus and i was like oh
sandbox nurse that that'll get me to
come outside
oh this is you know our car gets about
his sandbox i was excited about enough
about me we got a special guest
let us get this thing officially started
welcome to the last word episode number
173
exotic cars are zooming around mexico
zombies are back once again and the
battlefield is bigger than ever but when
it comes to destiny the difficulty has
been cranked up to 11 as most are
looking at aspirational content in these
quiet times our guest today fits the
bill of a hardcore destiny player in
many ways but he has been a hardcore
gamer for much longer multiple clears of
old-school rpgs and elite skill in many
fps games throughout the years was where
he first cut his teeth in gaming now you
can find him with proving that he is one
of the elites in most areas in destiny 2
because he has some accolades that most
of us would never dream of
so let's welcome a man who got so
excited about a destiny trailer he got
in trouble for it holding of many of the
rarest emblems in destiny student of the
all-knowing biff owner of over 1 000
grand master clears
and holder of some kind of record of 70
hours of grand master carries in one
week an actual fan of gambit which we
have to question here in just a little
bit
and making his social media swan song
for this time before heading off to
become a riverhawk and hang out with
swoop the one the only swifty how are
you doing sir
okay so how am i gonna like how am i
gonna like
you just introduced me too good i'm not
that good
you're pretty good you're pretty good
too good i'm not that good but
thank you so much for having me i really
appreciate it absolutely well this week
has been uh this week has been really
eventful um
as you three know um my discord got
hacked uh this week and it's it's been
really a stressful time it's been very
difficult dealing with uh
discord support emails and just trying
to get my account back i feel brother um
so that's that's just how you know you
made it when they're out here hacking
you man
trying to bring a great man down exactly
all of these feelings trying to hack a
brother
it's been an interesting situation but i
know i really appreciate the uh the
introduction um
as you said
uh i play destiny a lot i play destiny a
really really stupid amount
um i'm on the game seven eight hours a
day just grinding out and uh my favorite
activity at least until recently
uh gm's grand master nightfalls um ever
since season one
um i've always had an eye
as more of a sherpa uh somebody who
helps out other people
and uh grandmaster nightfall just seemed
kind of like the next step for me um
going into that area where
just get two people in the fire team i
know the strats i'm i'm a pretty good
player so you know help him out a little
bit you know nice nice that's kinda
i've been a destiny fan for a long long
time but
grandmaster nightfall is definitely
where i feel like i peaked um thanks as
far as my interest in the game and uh
kind of showcasing my skills
so taking it back a little bit within at
least the destiny stuff and we'll touch
on a couple things kind of about your
history
but i know i kind of joked about it on
the intro but you got to tell more
people because i know how you got in
trouble
because of destiny but you've got to
explain this whole situation
that a trailer caused you to get kind of
busted like i want i want everybody to
hear this one because it's actually
pretty funny
all right so
this is back and uh back a little bit
before house of wolves
and um
so i used to go to a uh well first off i
should say
my family is a long line of teachers a
lot of a lot of my family is teachers
and coincidentally because my brother
was looking for a job
kind of in the area about a year before
this happened he actually got a job as
an english teacher
for the school i was going to
um
yeah the crazy coincidence right so my
brother is my english teacher and um
[Music]
small world my brother's my english
teacher
and um
so what happened one day is uh
me my boys in class you know uh
we're like destiny a little destiny fan
group um
we all played be all at xbox 360s uh
back in the day
um and it was around the time of house
of wolves
and so we're sitting in my brother's
class
and uh so for perspective the teacher's
desk is like top left and then there's
like a little u shape and we're in the
bottom right of the u shape we're polar
opposite of his class and he's he's on a
little break period
and uh me and my three friends we're
sitting in the back um because it's
break time it's break time so pull up
the phone that's right
and then we see that bungie drops the
house of wolves trailer oh we're hyped
man we're like this is gonna be good
it's gonna be good
we're in class right so it can't get too
loud so
bottom right of the class polar opposite
for my brothers my teacher
we pull up the video we we cuddle
together a little bit put it out
start watching
and uh
i was a really hyper kid i had adhd
you could already guess where this one's
going right
might have been a little bit too loud uh
might have been a little bit too loud
and all my friends kind of hyped up and
uh
we actually got written up for it uh
because we were kind of like screaming
in the back of the class
oh you were kind of screaming he was
kind of
stupid
you're kind of screaming a little bit
and
so my brother notices it it's like what
are you guys doing and
uh we got written up for the serving of
class um
that's one of my fondest memories with
uh destiny at least trailer-wise anyway
i just found it looking back i just find
it so funny
such an endearing ask a follow-up
question swifty yeah go for it did you
say that you and your friends played
destiny on the xbox 360.
[Laughter]
this is fascinating because i actually
have been looking for somebody i've been
looking for somebody who played destiny
on the xbox 360 because i didn't know
anybody who did for
basically the entire time that destiny
was around like
i think i had some friends who didn't
have an xbox one
like for the first couple months but
then after like you know it came out in
september or whenever and then by
december
everyone i knew had an xbox one or a ps4
and i just never knew anybody who played
on the old console yeah well i hate to
need to break your case here um i did
play on the 360. but i didn't stay on
the 360. this happened when we were on
the 360. house of wolves you know second
expansion still in the 360. when king
came
came out
got ps4
okay when curse of osiris came out went
to pc so i've been on all three kind of
players okay yeah oh and you've had to
create three characters all from yeah
as of right now i have a stadia account
and i also have a playstation 5 and an
xbox series x that i bought um but
those are all linked right before yeah
we're just starting from scratch before
yeah before we start from scratch
yeah yeah start from scratch start from
scratch in the friend game too not just
the end game oh yeah
real stinger to kind of lose your friend
group and have to oh yeah
think about that yeah no no it's real
it's real i i i know the life
when i went to pc i was it was start
over can't believe i did it thanks to a
certain uh co-host here but steven here
down there oh
i wanted to ask you a question something
before this i know we're gonna get into
a lot of destiny talk but um a game that
you had on your gaming history that was
very intriguing to me because i am
lord turn-based i love turn-based games
and i saw final fantasy
tactics
i was very impressed let's talk about
that how did that whole thing start
so
the first ever gaming console that i
ever got to play with obviously um i
never got like a ds until later um and
so my older brother as a kind of a
hand-me-down when he got his ds
um he gave me his game boy advanced
color um
and he didn't have like two extensive uh
two too many games on it i think he had
dragon age um
and then or dragon quest it was called
something i didn't play much um but
of course he had pokemon red which i
definitely loved uh but the main game
that really hooked me and i was like
man this was before i was 10. i don't
know how i had like the mental power to
play this game as efficiently as i did
but uh the main game that kind of hooked
me up uh was a little known square enix
game called final fantasy tactics
advance
and this game is a turn-based rpg
kind of level up your
select different classes gather
equipment you know improve your
characters use spells abilities magic
shields cool [ __ ] right
so like i was enthralled by this game
and
for perspective this game is really long
like if you were to run through all the
destiny campaigns i'll run a final
fantasy tax advance maybe two and a half
times as long as that which
obviously like
kind of a low bar um just due to how
short some of the destiny story stuff is
but as far as like story content and
gaming nowadays this is a pretty long
game
and i'm confident in saying i beat it
about eight times
all the way through
and this is
my gaming you know gaming history is
like i would wake up just to get on and
do another run of this game it was so
fun
so great i'd love them that really
really got me hooked in the gaming
that's what sounds like yes solution
over there so with you because i
definitely i had to shout it out because
i it's rare that i i see another turn
based brother i feel like i feel like
sometimes i stand a load on that job i
don't feel like people pop that genre up
the way i love it
you have it you don't say i don't eat
not as much but i remember it's like
funny yeah well i played like heroes or
my magic growing up so i was like i
played my some of them
and
but i was like it's i haven't as much as
i've like progressed on i used to more
but i haven't played much okay i haven't
stuck with like xcom and all the more
recent ones i never got into i just kind
of missed that whole train
another reason why i brought it up is
because 50 is kind of like a disciple of
life in my mind right so it's like
remember we had biform yeah and we're by
for vibe because i didn't know by flying
turn-based either then he was talking an
x-column we just went into a whole
tangent life really likes turn-based i
learned yeah really quickly i didn't
know that brother i didn't know this
shout out to attic trying to gatekeep
final fantasy tactic it's my go cog not
yours like i'm not allowed to like to
get only the holy lord addict is
supposed to love the game can't be yours
how dare i like it
by the way i think he had a super chat
earlier if you all know if you missed it
he did yeah shout out to lord adam with
the two dollar stupid chat he's like how
do i get him to do more push-ups you got
to stay till the end i will do something
even though i literally just did your
push-ups i literally just did push day
so i'm barely gonna squeak i'm gonna try
and do a set of ten but yeah we'll see
save that to the end
let's get into these questions anybody
we got some more stuff for this travis
anything you want to know about our fun
and intriguing guests so far
yeah uh how old were you when destiny
came out
um so
we're talking beta are we talking
official release because the first
version of destiny i played was the open
beta and i believe at that time it meant
seven years ago now so 12.
yeah above 13.
just doing that to get that reaction
from you yeah thanks
appreciate it
loki
the
any opportunity you can to remind the
old men of this call
yeah that is crazy
and that is all we got for the last word
thank you guys very much that's where
we're going to wrap it up
we we'll get through the d-box it's too
late i missed my early bird dinner so i
gotta make sure i go get my uh beauty
sleep
yeah you used to get that average
citizens discount yeah hold on let me go
get my insurer and uh
[Laughter]
anyway
i will say the nice thing about my chat
though typically and i don't know what
caused this maybe just because i'm on
the calmer side not like crazy animated
guy
half of my chat is like my age or older
it is weird that like i've got a more
mature chat so shout out to everybody
who hangs out because
yeah
i swear half the time i'm like oh i'm
holding they're like not as old as me
i'm like okay fair enough
uh i'm bringing it back making it cool
but yeah because you don't floss dance
on your channel man
that is true i would look like a fool
trying that
my wife she can dance me i'm gonna leave
that to her
so i did want to ask as we have a pretty
hardcore destiny man on here and as we
get into this world of destiny
when it comes to
this time in destiny and what you've
kind of found an expertise in the world
of destiny is grand masters and most of
what i would call the end game in
destiny
and i wanted to ask you because we had
this topic before and kind of see where
you were at where are you at with
regards to
what destiny has for an offering in the
world of in-game the rewards grand
masters things like that do you like
where you're at do you like what the
difficulties do do you like do you think
the juice is worth the squeeze all that
type of stuff basically where are you at
in
kind of destiny's in-game at this point
since that's what i would say your
mastery kind of falls in
it's too easy
hmm
traffic's going like these days
woke up
like that's the show i'm ready for
yo i love when someone
my main statement in regards to
destiny's difficulty is um
it has a different kind of skill gap um
with most games like world of warcraft
for example like mythic rating um
which i've never done personally but
i've heard a lot from my friends about
um
is that
mechanics are still hard to perform
consistently at a higher level destiny
doesn't really have that so the main
skill gap in destiny
isn't skill or mechanics
or how fast you can collect keys in your
keyboard it's knowledge once you
understand the strategy
people of much less mechanic skill
than you'd think
are able to consistently complete
aspirational content
i believe there should be stuff
that is in the game that is more
tailored towards players
where
repeated clears repeated um difficulty
repeated activity repeated progress
is something that is consistently hard
and obviously
it's a no-brainer the more you do
something the easier it gets for you
it's just a universal fact of life
um speak it however
destiny to me currently feels like a
place where if i understand what to do i
will not have difficulty doing it
and that's kind of something that really
strays me away from the idea of calling
destiny a difficult pve experience
is because all i have to do is learn how
to do something
i don't feel like i have to perform i
never feel like i'm put on the spot i
never feel like there's a deep hard dps
check i need to hit i never feel like
i need to
overcome as a player
okay i just feel like i need to inhale
kind of the knowledge of what i need to
do the best most efficient way to do
something
and it can be reasonably expected of me
to complete that every single time i run
it back
like i
i've done this right obviously we know i
have a thousand grandmaster nightfall
quiz
you know there's a problem when you are
double carrying people through proving
grounds
and you don't wipe in 30 runs
there's a problem there
i am taking people with little
like less mechanical expertise
less knowledge
less understanding
sometimes i'm taking people through
their first grandmaster nightfall
or sometimes i'm taking people through
their first master raid
um whatever it may be and um
if they're able
to competently complete that activity
um
i think there's a little bit of an issue
there
personally and i don't mean that for
that to sound elitist or gatekeeping
whatsoever because i love
and let me just say this i know you guys
are tired of talking about trials
totally supportive of the move for
trials to go towards more people can get
flawless i love that i love it when
lesser skilled players
and the less hardcore are able to
triumph
and i wouldn't want things to change as
they are now
rather i'd like there to be options for
a more experienced
better player to test themselves i don't
want to lock people out of the ability
to do end game content
i want there to be so much
hard end game content that evolves out
of this end game content that can kind
of be completed by your average destiny
player
where you eventually stumble into those
things
that i load into them like [ __ ] i can't
beat this
i can't do it i need to get better at
the game at the end
of the trip
my entire life right now like literally
travis is gonna make it a petition to
have you permanently a member of the
election
you're speaking to him so like this is
what he's been preaching from what
continue i hate to interrupt you
you're in your bag
i think it's great do you agree with me
um
i want to load into an activity in
destiny 2
and just say
[ __ ] i can't do this
i want to fail
i want to see that failure
and i want to get out of that activity
and i want to get as good as i need to
be to go back and beat it
i've never felt that in destiny and
that's something that i believe is
sorely laugh
uh sorely lacking sorry or laughing
i don't think it's laughable oh i know
that was that was what your mind was
putting into your mouth and you're like
yeah the front of you slipped the front
of your sleeve yeah i gotta be a nice
guy i gotta be a nice guy uh i just i
just think it's something something
difficulty wise that destiny is sorely
lacking is those activities that just
make you rethink if you're even good
enough to attempt them
right i mean that's the kind of stuff i
want to see this is you're making a lot
of fantastic points chad is agreeing
with you travis is going crazy right now
but i wanted to ask you like
do you think
with everything you said right and as
far as the challenge and
and and and with the way the game speaks
to you and how you've been able to
handle the game and move forward when
you just have all these these amazing
clears and everything you got going on
do you think it's a situation where they
are making
a choice to say hey we are not gonna
push in that direction development wise
because of whether it be the numbers or
accessibility and stuff like that do you
think that is a con you know a conscious
choice on the dev side from them to not
push it in that direction and the second
question would be um
are there any games that you feel
that you get that from were you like yo
i gotta get better being that you're
saying audacity is not giving that to
you yeah yeah
uh absolutely so um
one of the things that um
uh one of the things that you just
mentioned um was that kind of getting
better um at a game
uh
i play mostly destiny um unfortunately
my um
my main game time is on destiny i don't
experiment with a whole lot of other
games
um
there have been a couple times when i've
kind of branched out to other video
games so i don't have a whole lot of
experience
in other other games of that category
where i really have to get better
um
i will say uh recently i've picked up a
game called a risk of rain okay um and
it's kind of this roguelike tactical um
uh ability crafter uh where your
character starts off very basic uh kind
of like league of legends spawned in
very basic and then as the game progress
as you get more gold as you move through
stages uh you have to kind of build your
character um
and it's been making me think a lot more
consciously about how i build my
character what equipment i use and what
the best way to tackle an activity is
um i'd say that's probably the closest
thing i've personally had to an
experience of like
okay i you know i need to approach this
differently what items do i need by this
stage how do i how do i go about doing
this um
but i still wouldn't say it's exactly
difficult i did try to get into world of
warcraft uh during one of destiny's down
seasons but it's just not the game for
me man i was like yeah it's probably
hard to get in now honestly i mean i
played forever ago
i played when you were in diapers
apparently no i'm just kidding
uh but no i mean seriously it's like
world of warcraft i've heard it's some
people have stuck with it for a while
but yeah it's like it's not what it was
but even world of warcraft is a
difference in difficulty versus having
the numbers and mechanics and things too
as you are one who tends to want
something that's really going to
challenge you um you strike me as
somebody who needs to play like
dark souls and go into trying to figure
out your build that's gonna work or see
if you can do these bosses without
taking hits or anything crazy like that
i mean that sounds like a challenge or
something like hades dude hades is a
fantastic game first off that like i
think i played at the start of this year
i was a little late to it i couldn't put
it down on stream it is so fantastic and
if you like that roguelike aspect of
risk of rain
on top of a fantastic story reasons to
play ways to make it more difficult
against you like the progression in that
game and a story for a reason to keep
progressing i think you would honestly
love hades and it can push you
really to think about especially as you
said builds because depending on where
you start what you go for and kind of
the buffs that you get hades may be like
a perfect game for you depending on if
it speaks to you like that one because
that for me
it was an amazing amazing game and i
think it's hidden a lot of boxes that
you just mentioned at a risk of rain and
more yeah
but like oh you have okay it's fun yeah
it's fun inflated
have you ever done like souls games do
you like those type of souls
uh i've played souls games like
360 era back when i was like
12 15 between that age i've never uh
never gotten too too into dark souls um
or souls i was thinking about picking up
bloodborne oh please do
super
seems super enticing unless we're gonna
get like a remaster soon i i swear
that's always on the edge of like
please give us i don't know how we don't
have a 60 frames per second version of
that at least by now like that still
boggles my mind
wait it was on pc was it not 60fps it's
not on pc
it's not on pc it's only on ps4
it's only on ps4 it's 30 frames per
second it's a pretty good casual game
yeah
but i was going to say but like
bloodborne securo like those are both
personally very like fantastic games
both of those are very good maybe casual
for maybe i'm a casual here compared to
travis but i still think they're an
enjoyable experience the final they're
the final boss in the second row some of
them are difficult final boss in sakura
was
he was quite a treat i'll say that oh i
remember your face on that stream
yeah
i mean yeah
yeah i was just saying like bloodborne
in particular i think is super easy as a
souls game that was my first i actually
would be curious how it would be going
back that's why i want to replace it if
you went back it would be a joke because
like that one i think i had played demon
souls in all the other souls games so
when i got to bloodborne i was like uh
an old hand and i think i beat that game
in like five hours the first time i
played it i died like twice i was just
like all right cool now we got a lead we
got elite gamer over here but yeah it
took me it took many more try
replay it
it's an easy game i'm not only it's not
cd streams travis yeah oh yeah
anyway bring it back to yeah destiny
sorry also made
it's all good um you were commenting
earlier on how you believe um or you
were asking me if you believed that i
thought
it was a part of bungie's process yeah
give us harder harder content um
absolutely 100
and i believe this is actually confirmed
that one of the twabs if i remember
correctly is they spoke on
not being able to focus as much
resources into a master mode difficulty
because the raids at base only see a
certain amount of engagement that just
doesn't make that a worthwhile use of
the developers time
and that sucks that really sucks
i also think
that's also partly due to the way that
destiny is portrayed um
so i believe that destiny and i mean i
don't think anybody's gonna disagree
with me on this one
nobody compares destiny to dark souls
right no when you think of aspirational
destiny activity
you're thinking
get my light level up so i don't get one
shot by enemies yeah basically mechanics
up
so i have to 360 on lights it's just a
completely different mindset of when
we're talking about the world as the
word aspirational
uh and so because destiny is portrayed
as such
uh such a more casually engaging game
a game that really grasps onto the
casual player base which is great which
is awesome
and every single game needs a casual
player base to survive yeah i feel like
the casual aspects of destiny in
comparison to other mmos
the player base split is just
catastrophically different i
you look at something like world of
warcraft and i could guarantee you a
much higher percentage of that
uh that community is geared towards the
end game versus destiny
and so i feel like because of the way
destiny is portrayed
um to be more of a heart
sorry not as much of a hardcore endgame
experience um more of a visually
enthralling
kind of uh
play at your own pace
uh game it definitely doesn't attract
that hardcore audience that it needs to
retain the numbers for bungie to want to
invest into something like that um and
i'm gonna sign off for a second
i love my clan leader life
right oh he's a great guy
um and we actually had this discussion
uh about raids and difficulty um we're
on the private chat one time um we were
just talking i think it was after we
worked in a spreadsheet for something
might have been after a gm or something
but he just brought me into a call uh
and we talked and
he actually came to a really really cool
uh
really cool alternative that i wanted to
bring up that i actually kind of agree
with let's get it
there should be easy moderates
that's probably that's probably a take
you haven't heard let's break it down
would that be like a match mode easier
to remove the mechanics i think
less less mechanics right so less
mechanics obviously less rewards you
would just be getting it from kind of
the whirlpool uh as far as awards and
not exactly like the rewards right
but what an easy mode raid would do um
and this is big off slip knife because
this this is a fantastic idea is it
helps to bridge the casual player base
into the harder difficulty
it gives the casual player base think of
it like a strike
okay
grandmaster nightfalls
right
people aren't going to do grandmaster
nightfalls if they haven't experienced
the bass strike yet absolutely and so
when you're presenting strikes to people
then they eventually want to say oh i
want enhancement chords i want prisms
i'm going to go do the 1370 version and
they're like oh i like this i like this
but i want adept weapons
and then they gear up and they do the
grandmaster nightfall
right now we're at a state in destiny
where
a large percentage of the player base
doesn't engage with raids
and i firmly believe that um obviously a
lot of that comes down to um
bungie's lack of matchmaking and ease of
access to find other players which yes
to be fair we have to credit them they
did send out the survey
yeah not a week ago
so hopefully
hopefully obviously friend gamer's
endgame is a really really strong uh
statement and i really hope that bungie
can live up to that because
the matchmaking offerings are just a
little bit weak at the moment in my
opinion that's that's a nice way to
phrase it
yeah
i'm a nice guy
yeah that's fair but yeah it's just a
little bit weak and aside from the
matchmaking systems just not
not being entirely up to par the way
that the game is presented to be way
more casual
on top of that
it gathers a lot of players
who would like to raid but aren't given
the resources to
i see the hand signs yeah we acted out
we it's like so many internal jokes
yeah it's me
it's like it's like i prepped you before
the show yeah
it's like i had a goal before
this over here is winning he dmd
privately was like all right so we want
to talk about these things i need you to
just speak let me just say yeah we're
not going to talk about the private call
we had like
yeah
the check cleared
now this is great this is great i love
it no it's like
i mean i've
after playing world world of warcraft
for you know a few years i've i've
mentioned it a couple times but as you
said like a million times every episode
yep yes it comes up a lot it's fair but
it is also one of the like just like
destiny has managed to live on past all
the destiny killers world of warcraft
has somehow managed to live on after all
the world of work have killed so there
are some
benchmark i was like it is one of the
few that's done something not everything
and of course there's ups and downs for
anything that lives that long but like
that is one of those things when they
implemented matchmaking
into even higher level activities like i
mean picture a grandmaster nightfall but
like a dungeon but a little baby dungeon
but i mean you had to kind of cue into
your role just like you would in an mmo
and the thing about destiny is in theory
you wouldn't even have to do roles in an
easy raid because the classes don't even
take on like tank heal there's no such
thing just all kind of run together and
as you said if you ran i'm just
picturing like vault of glasses in easy
mode you know you wouldn't have to
even use say like the relic on templar
to have that in the middle but you could
do some way to like have enemies spawn
for a certain point and then you know
after you survive for a while the boss
just somehow drops a shield and you can
just do damage to it so it's like more
of a time gate survival thing
and then stay out of the boss's way and
maybe it's a little longer and then he
moves after a little while and you got
to move like there are ways they could
do that
with everything that they've got in
there and i think you're right like it
doesn't have to be elite rewards and
again dumb down raid rewards may not be
right maybe decent drops or something
like that but
a way to have somebody be like hey this
is the vault of glass this is the easy
mode but it is match made same thing
when you go to like nightfalls at hero
after that you got to find a way to step
it up and you got to go look but at
least in hero you can get kind to
something if you put some time in and
then same thing you could do in there
maybe there's a chance at the end that
you might get one raid drop
if you complete the raid like something
like that you can do one non-adapter
anything just a chance at one if you do
the raid and if you do like the match
married raid like three times maybe you
get one gun you're like oh if i go do a
raid i'm gonna get like all this stuff
so it's like no i i totally agree that
something like that as somebody in chat
said to the
guided games got completely abandoned
that's just that system has
totally fallen off
and they need some way i mean that's the
problem is like you want
and it's always a balance bungie works
off of numbers and data and everything
else
the hardcore do want the hardcore
activities to do the very difficult ones
to push them the one that you walk in
you're like holy crap we just got wiped
and i don't even know where to start
like that's those moments that you want
to get into something that pushes you
that far but bungie's incentive to make
that is not very much in the first place
because they can barely get people into
the raids
and it's different for
and it would be one of those for a raid
if they made it manageable enough like a
strike takes 10 minutes it'll be like
hey a match made rate if they can make
it like 30 or 40 and be like hey this
and let people know it's going to be
about that long they can't make it like
a two-hour thing but if you could
survive as a group like we do six-man
match made activities now even though we
don't do six made legend which is still
a thing i think they should do and let
people struggle a bit but
yeah yeah i'm with you on that that
would be a way because again as you said
if there's no if people aren't making
the bridge towards some of that in-game
they're never even going to try to do
the harder versions much less the
hardest version so i agree yeah
i would say
a lot of it comes down to the way that
the game kind of
fails at matchmaking with other players
um
ideally looking to tackle that content
and
also the new player experience oh we've
talked about that oh my god
yeah new player experience is actually
something that i'm very fond of talking
about because i have an alt account i
have a free to play alt account so about
i want to say a year ago i got a little
bit bored of uh destiny's kind of
seasonal offerings and just
lack of things to do for a general
general idea and so started out i
decided to make an alt account uh and
this alt account had a couple goals
first off it was gonna be completely
free to play
if i was gonna buy anything it was gonna
be like an emote or an emblem or
something whatever cosmetic it wasn't
gonna affect my gameplay which is going
to lock me out of dlcs
and stuff of that nature
and um second off
i wanted to be a hardcore endgame player
and i didn't really know how well i was
gonna be able to
make those two things collide because
you lose a lot of content not having the
dlcs you lose a lot of options to get
pinnacle gear you lose a lot of stuff
um and you're very limited in what you
can do but i was actually pleasantly
surprised
that um i am one season off of unbroken
i can acquire the fate breaker seal
and i already have competent loadouts
for gambit crucible and
gms
not bad for free
yeah it's really not bad for free i was
now super super surprised so here's the
question
and this is i've thought about making
one too but honestly it's like i want to
put something out on twitter and be like
do you have somebody who's thinking
about playing destiny it's like i want
to literally play with them and be there
to answer their questions but tell them
nothing
because even for me i've thought about
this too because i can't figure out a
way to remove my knowledge
if i start a new account the same thing
that's like okay what are the things you
start and i would probably i was even
thinking about doing free i was thinking
about just you know making a new paid
account just to see how the progression
goes like yeah what am i missing what
resources like you know you think about
enhancement cores and people
occasionally where the hell do you get
those or mod components when you don't
have most of the mods like how long the
progression would take to get those
things
but then in turn i still know like okay
i need to go and do the gunsmith
bounties pick those up every day so at
least i can get some shards and some or
some mod components and some cores i
know where to go for a look in these
things as somebody who doesn't know
i think they would i honestly am very
curious to see how confused someone
would be who is completely clueless at
this game because i've thought about
doing what you just said you did but i
was like but even for me i'm like how do
i take out my knowledge and play stupid
like i want my wife to play i've joked
with her as like i want my wife to play
and i can answer all the questions
but i was like i can't tell her anything
now she's not a shooter so it's like
that'd be a whole learning curve in
itself but
like just the lack of knowledge in
destiny and see how clueless somebody is
for like a first time in and wonder how
hard it hits and be like i have no clue
what's going on they don't tell me
anything i'm out like
it's interesting i think it would be a
really cool experiment that somebody
needs to do
now i don't know if i'm going to be the
person dude but somebody needs to do
that because that would be a really good
insight
into the state of the new player
experience yeah um i personally believe
the introductory to the world is kind of
weak
um
uh people have been complaining about uh
the lore not being as easy to follow for
a very long time people have been
complaining about
the game not really pointing you towards
dungeons and raids and strikes and the
activities that you need
for a while
um as a free-to-play player i will say
my experience
basically consists of
doing banshee daily bounties for mod
components yeah periodically checking up
if there are any missing charged with
light or elemental well kind of mods i
need to buy from 801 or banshee
and then aside from that doing my
seasonal unbroken comp grid and uh my
very limited array of pinnacles so that
would be
vault of glass right here for this one
oh gosh let's get it vault of glass
prophecy
which remember is only the end encounter
the um the hawthorne clan rank up which
says it's a tier three powerful it's a
pinnacle
um
crucible gamut strikes
[Music]
not the most
extensive list
sadly there's not many satellites that
you're missing the exo um like agility
mission that's one of the pinnacles you
have
that's beyond light okay no i'm he's
that's what travis is asking what's what
are you missing
i was like and there's not a ton more
when you start to truly go because i
make this like leveling guide video
every year
or every season to be honest because
people tend to want to wonder what's
going on and yeah there's not a ton more
when you get to
when you get like 13 20 to 13 30 there's
not a ton of things that get you there
because you mentioned your plus ones the
pinnacles you got the raid which is
probably your most drops you got
prophecy already covered so then when it
comes to the other ones you've got
master
can you do the master nightfalls
or grandmasters i would say like 100k
nightfall can you do that as a free
player
it depends if the nightfall okay free to
play
which is basically never
so i most of the times i scratch that
one off the list
um which is interestingly enough
actually the same thing with grandmaster
nightfalls so the grandmaster nightfall
seal
as a free-to-play player is unobtainable
because you have to do
a it's not unobtainable for the reason
you might think
okay
most people assume oh you can't do
grandmaster nightfalls you can
they have to be free to play once there
are six free-to-play grand master
nightfalls in the game if i recall
correctly i'm at something like four out
of six okay so you can get that part
done you can obviously kill champions
you can obviously get a high score
nightfall
the reason why you can't do it is
because you have to do a grandmaster
nightfall on every subclass stasis is
one of the subclasses
because of that makes sense and uh
it's also very interesting um
dredjan
do you think i can get dredging
just
just shout it do you think i'm gonna
guess no yeah it's like i'm not sure the
specifics is the why but i'm gonna guess
no
probably something that has to do with
this malfeasance
malfeasance malfeasance is the only
thing stopping me from getting a 10 part
seal the one part
because it is a forsaken era quest
even if you kill the meatball in gambit
it gives you the quest i don't
understand try to talk to the drifter
and uh he's like
are you holding something brother i
can't see it
so
can't get it right and obviously
that 20 bucks so you can own forsaken
for three weeks
absolutely not three weeks it's only
three weeks why why that's yeah we're a
month out because they're
yeah they're taking it away
well maybe potentially after
well hey when it's free then you'll be
able to get get it there so yeah
question is when that actually goes away
what are they going to do with like the
malfeasance quest we have we'll talk
about it but we have like whisper coming
back but you have whisper and outbreak
catalysts that still have no path
even if you grind for the weapon through
say the um kiosk you still can't get the
catalyst and they
how
just put it in the game i'm going to say
that now before we get to the 12 just
put it in the game like i feel like
they're like okay here's the new season
here's like one
two catalyst that's it no more no more
just two
and i feel like that's how they're
they're like slowly doling these
catalysts out or and i don't know if
it's like the testing that gets to be an
issue or whatever and they mention
something else for some of at least the
orb generation but those two especially
just because they've been in there so
long and the catalyst exists like the
function is there people just can't get
it just make it drop from
lost sectors night i don't care just
make a drop somewhere in the game that's
just random offshoot sorry
yeah no no i agree
i feel they were kind of doing it i felt
like each season i'd do a strike and
randomly get some catalysts you get like
one or two when you start a new season
and that's it
yeah but those ones would be the most
annoying thing for them to attach it to
catalyst drops
how about every time you delete an item
in your vault you get a chance i got a
lot of chances i got a lot of chances
i don't want to delete everything either
so that's probably could pull a
leviathan's breath and lock a pinewood
wrath warnings
quite the exhaustive one oh
we're going to talk about
the one and only time i have interacted
with rathborn hunts
is before day one vault of glass to get
a deafening whisper because of breaching
clear with wave frame grenade launchers
goes crazy
and also at the time
this was my favorite gun for the season
because of the mod that let you make war
mod cells with void explosions
and so you basically had martyr's
retribution on sunset in the current
meta with breaching clear like
that's crazy
i figured it out
they should put the catalysts behind
solo queuing in the non-freelance trials
playlist
the only way to get it
i can't you have to solo play
non-freelance trials
that would that would be the worst way
to do it you have to go flawless
you have to solo queue into the main
playlist you have to go flawless that's
right
solo flawless in the main playlist
this guy took my idea and made it it's
so much worse way worse so much worse
but hold on we can make this worse let's
get it why would it also has to be
during the week of flag captures
trials labs only trials
only you're locked into it for i don't
know how many months
oh my god you better gather the squad
all right before you make too many
people squirm in their seats or if
they're driving they're crying right now
um yeah the new player experience
definitely could need some work but it
is impressive to see how far you've
actually come but it is annoying to see
some of the very specific limitations
like you can't get xenophage for example
i know that one you can't even touch
like there's quite a bit of stuff that
is locked away so
that's a great experiment you're really
you're really doing the lord's work here
uh
because that's like that's like true
dedication going through all that just
to see what to see yeah to see how it is
yeah i have all three characters almost
that pinnacle cop again and i have like
good roles like i'm competent in game
activities um funny enough i missed i
have the flawless seal this is because
this account existed before
they changed trials to not be accessible
to free to play counts
but you can't guilt you can't killed it
i can't guilt
if i didn't already have it i couldn't
get it now okay but
i do have the flawless seal that's
impressive
that is impressive
there's that
not bad
well gentlemen we do have a meaty twab
to say the least so we probably should
talk about that just a little bit
there's a few things in here nothing too
specific just a bit uh first thing
though uh definitely always bungee doing
some proper things out here so i want to
read this little part there's a free
emblem for you guys but i'm going to
give you guys a little rundown everyone
at bungie both trans developers and
allies alike stand in support of our
transgender and gendered
non-conformation communities we join the
call to end anti-trans violence and
discrimination the stars burn brighter
because of your courage unwavering
strength and pursuit of truth ahead of
transgender awareness week we which
celebrates the lives of the transgender
and gender non-conforming community from
november 13th through november 19th we
are proud to announce our new trans
pride emblem be true
your light inspires helping guide us all
on a path to a better future may it only
shine brighter as transgender awareness
week leads into transgender day of
remembrance on the 20th a day to
memorialize the lives lost to
transphobic hate and violence we also
recognize the hardship this community
faces
we invite anyone and everyone to join us
in remembrance by donning this new
emblem and there's a code you can use to
unlock it just attach it to your account
and just literally just jump on the twab
codes there pretty straightforward and
easy they're also going to have all
sales from bungie's pride pin
um during the month of november will
benefit trans lifeline in support of
their efforts to provide peer support to
trans people in crisis throughout
throughout through respect anonymous and
confidential communication and resources
bungie's just always out here honestly
just leading the way when it comes to
literally like being a a beacon of like
what companies can hopefully strive to
be and once again just standing out
right here so i mean literally i've
spoken to some developers you know
yeah you've watched some go through on
twitter and things like that so shout
out to bungie for being as open and
welcoming and supportive of yeah just
like just people in general in all ways
in general yeah they always they don't
get their roses for that they they do so
much for the community all communities
and and they really get behind it and
put their money where their mouth is
kind of thing and you got to respect it
you got to respect it i being from trans
community you know the pride pin i
remember the uh what is the black lives
matter pin you know they're always
bringing awareness you know what i'm
saying so you got to salute that and
they the inclusion of bungie to not
leave anyone out i always respect that
so salute good luck
so i know that was a short little piece
we definitely had to shout it out
because you know always a good thing to
do
yeah
now we get into the interesting stuff
the twabage
the meat of the twab you could say that
was just the uh the amuse
that was the appetizer
all right back to the lab again so i'm
gonna give you a quick rundown of trials
because we've literally talked about it
every week of the season so far and they
are still keeping us to it this one will
be a little shorter though uh because
the meat of the twab is also the sandbox
which cognito cannot wait for
yes this would be be careful what you
wish for travis
i want to talk about trials every week i
know right that's true right that's true
we want pvp to be a focus all right here
you go
here you go
we are not going to shut up about it
exactly pvp sandwich
so uh coming up this friday tomorrow
depending on when you when you're
catching this one they are going to do
trials labs and they're going to revisit
the capture zone trials uh same pieces
are going to work for 30 seconds after
the round starts the capture zone is
enabled you can see where the round is
going to excuse me where the round is
going to be from the start of the round
including the timer
capture zones start in the middle of the
map in the first round and we'll change
locations
differences this time they have a
stronger map for trials which is endless
veil
rather than rotating through points that
give one side an advantage or the other
they're all gonna be neutral zones so if
you picture three lanes it's just gonna
be on the middle of those lanes probably
uh and players no longer get super
energy when capping a zone either before
or after the round ends people were just
like kind of sandbagging on them after a
little while so
we're piling on basically and the
matchmaking is going back after the you
know
cumulative win thing that was trashfire
on twitter which we talked about last
week
it is going back to card based
matchmaking only and the flawless pool
will return on sunday at 10. also with
trials labs you have two times
reputation so if you're looking to get
some of those engrams some armor unlock
some of those this is definitely a
weekend and trials labs will be an
interesting experiment but yeah
definitely if you're not going for a
flawless card by the way my advice use
the passage of wealth i think it is
because you get bonus reputation for the
whole way through yeah so you may as
well use that unless you just plan to go
flawless because if you're just trying
to solo you in probably not going to
happen so you may as well get the
reputation good point good point i
always do that because i'm not going
flawless by myself at least if i find
people to randomly play with or i jump
in a backpack that'd be different but by
myself wealth the whole time
you guys have any thoughts about this
one are they good changes are you
curious to see is trials just like are
you done with trials at this point
are you even gonna jump in
i'm so exhausted with trial um look the
tweet the tweet the the weekly tweak the
weekly tune-up
taking the card we're going to you know
to pet boys
that's what this is like every you know
we're doing this we're doing that
yeah you put your car on the rack this
is what we're doing you don't say so
i'll jump in it's back it's not our
banner you know how we do and i'll see
how it goes i i really don't have too
much to say on it but you know again in
defense of what you said you know i
can't complain about they don't pay pvp
any mind and then they give it to us and
they're at least trying to do something
which hopefully gets to our nirvana
state of
pvp balance and rewards and what we want
so that's all i got it but i was curious
about trav and of course
yeah yeah swifty ahead
i didn't like
capture the flag last time um my main
my main grievances but the the idea was
just that it promoted really passive
play and so to be fair the ideology
going into this was that bundy
specifically stated they wanted to
reduce the amount of blowout games no
more o5s no more 50s
so that people felt like they had a
chance people were winning rounds so
they were making progress towards their
trials loot right
the issue
that i found personally i know a lot of
other people had very mixed opinions
some people really liked it some people
really hated it i'm kind of in the
middle um
but more so towards the no side of
things
simply because i felt like my games were
a lot more passive
if you were ever to get the advantage on
your
on your opponent
spawning the cap point in their spawn
it just led to a lot of stag rifts and
uh
a lot of nonsense a lot of passive play
which to be fair is trials in a nutshell
anyway uh
but
i'm
i'm just not the biggest idea i think
it's really good that they're using
endless veil that's a pretty decent map
for that in my opinion it's good um
one at temple one at mid one at trine
also
definitely
better better than wormhaven uh spots
for sure um
and not getting super energy is very
good
that change needed to happen and it
happened props them on that
uh
yeah that's my
that's basically just my overall
thoughts is i i appreciate that they're
experimenting with it again with some
different parameters
i don't foresee it going a whole lot
better than wormhaven week it could
not sure
let travis talk though
yeah
i i didn't actually get to play last
time there was a capture zone experiment
um i can't remember what was happening
that weekend but i couldn't play um so i
will probably play this week just to
check it out but yeah i i heard kind of
the feedback on twitter that you know
the games were really passive and that
the mode was imbalanced i'm interested
to see
how things go but i'm still an advocate
for i honestly thought the bomb assault
was better mode for trials because that
forces at least one of the teams to not
play passively and sort of like get up
in the other team's face
i am glad they're trying different modes
i think that the uh
the mode they have for trials is a
little tired i also think it doesn't
really match how the game mode
how the game mode is curated now right
like
the the whole elimination is is sort of
meant for
people in fire teams working together
and having like this ultra sweaty
experience and now trials is a lot more
casual and has people that aren't in a
fire team and not being in a fire team
as cog and i have learned over the past
weeks and in e as well who's also played
freelance um the elimination
mode does not really lend itself well to
three people who all are not talking on
mic because one guy runs off and gets
picked and the other two people just get
destroyed because their teammate you
know was was trying to rambo it um i
don't think that really works with that
mode so i think they kind of have to
find a new
a new mode if they're gonna
keep trials
casual and have matchmaking in it then
the mode that they built isn't really
designed super well for that so i am
glad they're trying new stuff but yeah
we've talked about trials ad nauseam i
think uh people know where i stand on it
it's probably not a mode that i will
play as often now just because it's a
little bit um you know you get through
it really quickly there's not anything i
need uh from it from a loot perspective
and it's also not
incredibly compelling from a competitive
perspective because matchmaking is such
a crap shoot um so
yeah uh i'll definitely play it this
weekend just to check it out and see how
the um
the uh the capture zones work but that's
it
no that's fair yeah i was like it'll be
an experiment i think overall
at least for them trying the capture
zone the changes they made seem positive
at least the ones people were asking for
as for the success of the actual zone
itself we'll have to see and as travis
said it's like
if you had freelance and everybody's in
chaos but it's like if you're if you get
paired up with this three stack in
something objective base you're probably
going to be in trouble unless you're
like an elite trying to see how it goes
but generally yeah as he said
one
one guy goes off and leroy jenkins is it
and gets hit in the face and then all of
a sudden you're down so then you're just
outnumbered and it's already tough so
you have your moments sometimes they go
okay sometimes they go poorly but
usually as a solo player it's a mediocre
experience at best
yeah it'd be good if they had a mode
where like even if you weren't in
a fire team in a party chat it was very
clear what the whole team had to do
right like that's what the good thing
about the bomb assault is like you don't
have to be talking to somebody but even
a
blueberry knows that they have to defend
their bomb or they have to plant the
bomb
at somebody else's site but in in just
regular elimination it's like go run
wherever like there's no real like
obvious way to approach it so people
sort of just like break off and run and
get themselves killed and i think it
would be cool if uh there was like a
much more obvious objective for like
people that aren't on a fire team if
that's how they're gonna keep doing
trials no
well we will see how the experiment goes
and it kicks off tomorrow at 11 since
daylight saving time is now off for at
least the u.s so depending on if that
might happen to you time has switched a
little bit so 11 o'clock in the morning
for me for zur instead of newton
but we have a lot of changes to the
sandbox so i'm going to try and hit the
high level pieces on these for the
changes there's any high notes in like
kind of the description as to why i'll
touch on those and then i'll see about
feedback on each of these so if you want
to go deep on anything otherwise you
guys would be like yay nade type quick
stuff but we'll go through the weapons
the exotics the perks a lot of changes
come in and this is all changes that are
going to be coming with the 30th
anniversary
that's on december 7th so we are just
about four weeks away from that at this
point so i'm not too far but is is is
the 30th anniversary a new season are
they going to do its own season pass and
all that no i think it's just going to
be kind of the infusion of you've got
the dungeon the thorn armor from the
dungeon you've got the six player
activity which is going to be kind of
that new thing for i think more of the
bungee ornament type stuff is going to
be in there like all the 30th like all
their history type things gallahorn
quest and catalyst is going to be in
there i think that's mostly just like an
infusion of like content but like your
season pass i think it's just still
gonna keep going they've if they reset
the season pass at this point you can
no
i'm sorry but yeah there's no way
there's no story constant to go through
there's nothing really keeping you
around in the dungeon while cool will
not last that long to keep us going for
another three months so it is still
gonna be season the lost i'm pretty
pretty sure
but as for the weapons um archetypes are
first we're gonna go through the main
ones shotguns are the starter so of
course um you know
fallout at least doesn't have to do too
much research on this one
for his sake uh but basically they
really seem to be trying to put a little
kibosh on the
anarchy slug shotgun quick switching
meta that's been going on because
they do slug shotgun pve damage
bonus from 30 percent to 20 and they
gave pellet shotguns a 10 pve bonus
because i said they're easier to use
than slugs but again
uh like
however the current out
they currently outclass pellets shotguns
this is talking about uh slugs and many
other special ammo options not to
mention being part of a dominant boss
belting tactic so i mean they call it
out very specifically as to why i just
didn't do you guys
deep stone crimp
excuse me i mean
templar's the same way but yeah both
like both of them um do you guys see
this is like too much too little you
guys okay with this change do you even
use shotguns that much in pve outside of
just the boss melting slugs
swifty
uh
i don't think the slug shotgun nerf was
entirely necessary so part of the reason
why slugs were so good is because you
could pair them with anarchy um
anarchy got
a big reduction in the damage it was
doing to bosses
this combo is still very effective and
very good but especially in a season
like
linear fusion and fusion rifle city
you're not really seeing slugs baking
bosses at the moment because we
currently have a 41 debuff for fusions
and linear fusions right
i think overall for the state of the
game
i understand why slugs would get nerfed
but and i definitely i'm very supportive
of pallet shotguns getting a damage
bonus because they are quite literally
relevant in the current meta yeah and
they have been for
ikelos shoddy
the last
non-slug shotgun that was good in this
game so before beyond light
uh
yeah it's uh
the pilot shotties needed the love man
um slug shotties
the damage pve bonus from 30 to 20
that's a 10 damage loss that's a lot uh
what it may be like to see it down like
five or something i think that's a
little bit
that's a little bit much a little steep
especially as something's about to get a
buff in the next one
yeah
it's just uh it seems a little bit
unnecessary for a 10 damage nerf
in my opinion
yeah
it feels kind of like uh it gives the
same kind of vibes when legendary
snipers were very good mm-hmm and then
shadow and then shadow keep uh yeah yeah
shot those in the face
yeah kind of came around and uh
gave legendary snipers the tea bag and
uh
yeah yeah no i gotta go off on a random
tangent though uh
vlad had mentioned something he's like
what is
the main focus of the tea bag
is the fact that the
the is it the fact that the tea bag
resembles a very specific piece of
anatomy and or is it the up and down
motion that you're doing that is like
the tea bag in the water what is the
main focus here
both
to portray disrespect to your objectives
yes that's clearly whatever means
whatever means necessary and
mm-hmm uh
so it's more the bag not the action
it's the meaning it's what you mean when
you bag somebody it's understood that
you're giving this guy like the
metaphorical [ __ ] you you know
like hold on let me make note of that
time stamp that nope
we're losing all the sponsorship now
yeah it's all gone now it's over
actually
your first mistake
no no you're good
above this late in the show they'll
probably never know
the focus is bags
that's the answer to that question
anyway
i saw that tweet and he said it and it
just sparked my memory so i just had to
bring it up for a second
linear fusion rifles uh in season 14 we
bump these up but while their potent
damage output come competes numerically
they're extra hot right now because of
sweet particle deconstruction artifact
mod they can't compete with ease of use
of other damage options so last time
they got a precision damage buff this
time it's a flat damage buff of 10
so all i can say is uh from december 7th
to
february 22nd linear fusion rifles are
just going to be parked in your heavy
slot in pve because that's yeah they're
already strong with particle
deconstruction they just got 10 percent
more across the board so yeah yeah
they're not going anywhere
yeah
i like it you know for me
it's needed because let's be real
it's it's particle deconstruction that's
been always happening
yeah without particle deconstruction we
would still be rocking these linears
like that it's just the optimal meta
right so to me
that i like the idea of the initial buff
of the 10
you know precision damage or whatever it
was but overall pve yeah let's get that
let's get that um you know that get that
damage up even on body shot or whatever
because
it it makes it more viable i just felt
like
comparatively to a lot of the other
heavies especially legendaries like it
just wasn't and then we gonna get it to
my sleeper soon oh yeah we'll get there
you know we'll see the
blue cave dps strat probably linears
just just a guess especially because if
there's champions in there we got a
linear in that kinetic slot that's going
to be very very useful but we'll get
there
uh caster swords literally on tuesday if
you guys saw my community post there was
a decent caster sword sitting out there
for purchase hopefully you got it uh if
not sorry
but they are gonna reduce the heavy
attack ammo from eight to five castro
swords have a little bit of a little
less ammo than normal swords in the
first place so then if you did throw
that caster which they do say you know
it has a strong melee attack and also is
decent at range but it was very
expensive to throw that range so your
ammo did kind of hit pretty hard it's
just as cheaper to throw the heavy cast
out there so if you have like a chain
reaction solo scar
you might be blowing some more stuff up
would be a guess
yeah
thoughts sounds like anybody have any if
you guys don't have any thoughts then i
can move but if you guys don't use
casters like that so shout out to the
cast of gang let's go i'm down with that
i'm very down with that caster sword
heavy economy ammo economy is really
really bad it's one of the main turn
offs of using that archetype
it's a very cool idea very cool concept
it's also really cool with stuff like a
solid scar one of the standout rules for
solid scar is chain reaction and
tireless because you're essentially
refilling your ammo economy yeah every
single time you hit something with even
a normal attack um
the issue with caster swords
is that there's almost never an
incentive to use the caster part of the
sword
yeah
which
i think it needed this ammo attack
reduction and or sorry this uh this ammo
cost reduction and if anything i'd also
love to see it get a little bit of a
damage bonus for just using
the caster part of this yeah yeah
just because you do more damage just
light attacking over and over again
bringing heavies into the mix i think
yeah um
yeah relentless strikes are still going
to be ultra powerful i'm pretty sure
just wailing away on something
agreed i did goof around probably in
like one random lost sector one season
with a sword and i'm like all right i'm
gonna see if i can do this with a caster
i got it done but i would never
recommend it
um bose in season 11 they said they
bumped up bow damage 10 versus rank and
file it's gonna be your red bars having
seen this in-game for a few seasons
seems safe to nudge them up again so
again pve damage against rankin files
for bows approximately 10 more percent
i love bows in pve so this is no problem
for me i love smacking
i i have no problem like i love using my
bows when i get a chance to and if they
just are easier to kill those red bars
because i'm sorry like a full drawn bow
the way as slow as it is i shouldn't
have to two tap pretty much anything
most of the time i mean at night maybe
but like acolyte stuff like that
especially in higher level stuff every
so often you're like why does it take
two
yeah i rank a file
yeah i agree with that i'm
kind of surprised they didn't exclude
tikkus from this
in all honesty because it's kind of just
like really [ __ ] good
i support the damage uh increases
i don't really think it was necessary
but it's welcome
bows are already definitely a slept on
option um for pve general usage but
they're also the best overload in the
game oh 100
so i'm always for gm's i'm always
running a bow uh whenever it's the
overload season and uh
yeah but bows are great man i love bows
so much the damage increase is really
going to get felt on
yeah a lot and uh
tikkus
yeah two could be nice i am scared for
how good it is
nice
yeah that one when the season that one
dropped i mean i don't get to use and
then like the way trinity ghouls
catalyst which i don't know if that was
the same season as well or if it was off
but like trinity to ghouls catalyst and
tikku's divination man those are so much
fun for ad clear yeah
overload
beautiful
real nice
the last change for weapons is an odd
one um it's actually mostly for i think
consoles that are not running 60 frames
per second or higher but basically they
said due to an ancient data entry error
hashtag spaghetticode
sidearms and fusion rifle projectiles
were non-hitscan now i figured fusion
rifles were non-hit scan always because
the way they have their
the bolts travel but sidearms where
non-hit scan kind of boggles my mind a
little bit because i figured most things
that fire bullets always were
behind the scenes the engine does math
converting projectile from non-hit scan
to hit scan if it would cover a specific
distance in one frame
if you're wondering how coding game
works there's evidence that it's a
little complicated
so this would only occur running at 60
fps or higher shout out to a specific
community that provided us with evidence
on this issue
so okay i guess or i could be reading
this backwards is this for people
running like 144 frames it was not
running hit scan or for people on like
ps4
which side is gonna get the benefit out
of this because they basically increase
the projectile speed from 999 to
9999 which basically makes it scan
regardless so i'm trying to like who
gets the benefit here because i feel
like i'm reading it wrong
uh
would only occur
running 60 fps or higher i believe
they're saying
sidearms and fusion rifles being non-hit
scan would only occur at 60 fps or
higher if i'm reading that correctly
so then people with like 30 90s and
crazy computers running 144 frames
or like 1080 240 whatever if you're
going high frames i guess they were not
technically hitscan and now they will be
so apparently high fps you're gonna feel
a little better on those two weapons
not a bad thing seems like that's a
proper fix
i believe that's how it's read i could
be wrong it could be the other way
around
i know it's like i was like it's awesome
a little bit oddly worded as always but
that's bungee for you so gotta leave
some question marks in the game
exotics now we're gonna have some
interesting chats here
uh vex method class is number one on the
list and no surprise uh yes we over buff
this of course
um
and while it's kept in shot by the peak
shot potential of hand cannons it's
definitely melting faces they didn't
want to kill it in pve which i am
thankful for
so they're reducing the aim assist at by
25 reduce the linear fusion rifle mode
aim assist cone by .05 and the reducing
requires three eliminations for full
overcharge instead of two
thoughts for my vex users because i'm
not one of them
let me come to the front of the
congregation
yeah look boys it was a good run
but i don't think it's gonna be nerfed
to the ground i i mean this is just my
thought initially i do feel it you know
how i feel about
auto rifles
in general and in my opinion effects is
an automatic 100 percent you watch
people play
but you're also getting like particle
deconstruction while stacking i'm
watching people do like gm's and it's
just like the auto rifle with range
fusion particle i'm like it's winning
this season there's no question right
my my only issue with x is a
vex is a fusion rifle in the same way
that tomatoes are fruit
exactly look at the end of the day my
only issue with it it reminds me of when
we had season of the hard light my only
issue was that was just like the aim
assist from distance it's just too good
like i'm i'm beating out pulses and
scouts and stuff like that from a
distance i feel that they should
dominate in you know what i mean and
that was my only issue i mean i was
benefit of it because obviously i had
the weapon you know who i was facing in
trials didn't have the weapon so i had
no problem winning every engagement with
that but you know in fairness i don't
have a problem with that the the aim is
this code i have to be honest when i'm
in uh what is it overcharge mode lydia
fusion uh rifle mode i feel it's
ridiculously sticky like i feel like i
when i get a the stack i'm not missing
someone and i'm and you know i don't
even snipe like that from the linears
linears in general have a pretty
generous aim assist like our balance got
to tone down a little bit but arbor list
i heard on console was ridiculous at a
point i think it was console but i mean
linear fusions
yeah you can especially in pv i'm like
oh i'm somewhat above the head still
pulls yeah
yeah yeah
yeah they're they're generous on the
linears for sure yeah it it it had
magnetism but um
look i don't think this is too crazy i
still think it's going to be good but
i'm curious about what what swifty and
travis have to say because um
you know i feel right now it's you know
it's dominant yeah if someone's peeking
with you with a head you know with a
good 140 another hand cannon they can
get you out of there but for the most
part you know vex is going to win those
games and they're not really even
talking about the damage buffs with the
catalyst and all that even so to me it's
still going to be good but i want you
guys thoughts on it
yeah uh i honestly think this is the
best way they could have gone about it
and i'm very very happy with this um
the one thing looking at vex method
class that i didn't want to get changed
is how good it was in pve
yes
they didn't touch pve at all i'm very
happy about that if it was gonna get a
damage decrease
something like that agreed those are
fighting words right yeah i'm with you
i'm with you brother really good so good
in pvp fantastic oh
it's
solar shield
it's just
it has the destiny engine magic it just
feels like a destiny gun it's great i
love it
i think reducing aim assist is the way
to go because the biggest grievance
point of this gun
is it's ease of use in pvp yes so we
kind of get the amos's tune down a
little bit it becomes a little bit
harder to use more of a skillful weapon
to hit those shots especially in linear
mode um you just you point somebody's
zip code and it's a headshot yeah it's
like
[Music]
i think this is the best way they could
have gone about changing this gun and
i'm super happy about it what do you
think travis
yeah uh
i'm glad that they've been giving uh
some of the seasonal aspirational
weapons like great weapons if their
moment in the sun before they get nerfed
i think that's probably like an
intentional tactic is i like that
because it gives you a reason to like
actually grind for it in the season that
it's relevant because you can always get
it later but then you're like an xbox
player getting hawkmoon when it finally
oh god don't get us started that's a
deep car right there
yeah like
like who even cares at that point i was
one of those people by the way i was one
of them people too like yeah right to
pour out some liquor for us because we
never got it in its original form
that we were never there for the
pinnacle
um but yeah uh i i think fix your face
and i agree i'm glad that they've been
keeping these uh these nerfs
kind of separate because obviously pvp
is the problem with vex and i'm okay
with it being gone because i had my fun
with it i got it that first week of raid
so i can never complain like i got to
use it the minute you got time that it
was relevant i feel bad for people who
are getting it now yeah
situation like they're just gonna kind
of miss the window you missed the laser
tag weekend unfortunately lazy dog
yeah sorry
yeah although have you been doing the
right every week me no no no
exactly
complaining about you know i need all
right i fully 100 get that but i will
say occasionally i will see a tweet and
somebody's like oh finally got it on my
54th raid and i'm just like when i see
stuff like that i'm like if that is my
journey
man that's painful it's but i was like
yeah i need to read more
yeah it couldn't
yeah we all got those guys bro i bro
i don't need to keep repeating this
process i feel you brother bro i cannot
get 1 000 voices to drop it refuses it
refuses you shout out to dj's in the
chat
bro i go to the chest that somebody went
to the follow week where they got it
it's just
garbage
cause it's coal in my stock everybody
everybody's party and i got coal in my
stocking you know i'm like come on man
a full master vault of glass and then
two master atheon checkpoints every week
for like
a very long time now um
i got my vex at i want to say clear 50.
bife got his i think it was
53.
barb still doesn't have his
he's still looking
so all three of us have been i mean
we were so down bad for the long wait
every single week it's just the chest of
disappointment over and over okay let me
ask you this
when when do do you think there should
be a cap when that thing finally is
guaranteed to drop
yes i think
so here's the thing um
a raid exotic to me
feels there's two reasons uh why this
one is a great exotic
it should be a skillful thing it should
be like i got rewarded with this thing
because i was good at something right
um for one uh vex was the only thing
keeping me from getting my fate breaker
seal for like weeks on end right weeks
like i completed all like uh when that
final
master vault of glass challenge came out
i completed that one and then all i had
left to do was vex and then fast forward
like two months and then i finally got
it right
uh
i feel like there should be some kind of
condition where once you've done the
raid enough and they've done this in the
past apparently this is a thing with vex
as well where every single time you hit
a completion it goes up by two percent
or something somewhere right yeah what
happened to that drop protection
remember that yeah it seems busted as
i'll get out the drop protection
actually was busted for a deep stone
crypt i remember tweeting
for
yes
uh it was not going up as it was
supposed to be i agree
yeah that was unfortunate i got pretty
lucky i got mine early on then i didn't
have to suffer through that i know one
of my friends that took 84 clears we're
not going to talk about that um
it's just i feel like there should be
some sort of avenue um even if you
wanted to go like the spoils route um
just make it so that you could farm
spoils for the exotic um
something like that i think it should
just it's just it's such a deal it
should come with
it should come with the seasonal triumph
like you should just remove getting that
from the uh
uh the seal you know what i mean like
the the prerequisite to get it but it's
a guaranteed drop if you do everything
else in the seal you know what i mean
increase do you increase the rate for
that increase
actually cool increase the rate based on
the other things you've done for the
challenge like significantly to almost a
guaranteed state because if you've done
everything and you're just waiting for
it yeah a random drop that's yeah that
should be the protection like it should
come with the seal
see my only issue with that
uh initially just initial thoughts
is um we were talking earlier in this
podcast obviously about how destiny has
kind of poor matchmaking and um doesn't
really incentivize people into endgame
contact unfortunately because you need
to do master vlog which means you both
need to have a team have a very [ __ ]
good team well not very [ __ ] good
have a team have a competent team
um and be somewhat practice that the
activity will lock a lot of people out
of getting that exotic
um
and so setting it behind the completion
of your entire seal
is like you could also get it from a
random job
this is interesting
i've always thought like they should
have the luck version for people who
just want to grind it out but they
should also have a guaranteed version
for the people who just have really
terrible luck and that yeah that you can
either you can either choose skill or
you can just choose like persistence
because there's still going to be people
who go no i'm never going to do master
vlog i'll just wait for it to drop
organically you know
but yeah sorry
i support that yeah i'm very down with
that
yeah saved me no i mean we've talked
about this before and it's like if
there's a direct path of check boxes
that i could do that i guarantee that i
would get it because if you were up to
54
master clears or whatever it's like
if for how how long did it take you to
check all the boxes for say like
flawless or for what is it rift breaker
whatever the the seal is what you were
talking about like how long did that
take you to check all those wait
breakers breaker sorry yeah fate breaker
yeah uh i got it
the first moment it was available
besides the vex mythoclast so the last
triumph
that you had to do for that seal was the
final master mode
like four or five weeks like basically
master on each one or the challenges or
something yeah yeah just master
challenge on each one so you had each of
the encounters the challenge mode once
you completed all five of those popping
that triumph would get you the last um
the
shotgun the shotgun from the raid that i
can't found verdict you would get tom
lost found verdict which was the one
that you couldn't get from any of the
other encounters yeah because there was
an overflow of one weapon
tied to each other
yeah and so um yeah obviously i had
already had most of my stuff completed
and so it was just vex and then at that
point it's kind of just a waiting game
until rng yeah so if you're telling me
like yeah if you do it every week that's
five master clears that's a hell of a
lot of work already and then if you
check some of the other boxes like that
seems reasonable but it's like the whole
world of just forever rng there needs to
be an alternative venue
for raid exotics because if i sit there
and i look at a treadmill of like
possibly 54 raids or something i'm like
that's
forever
that's a long ways and it's like and at
this point i'm like why start the
treadmill i could get lucky like travis
or i could get the crap into the stick
and there's no way to know but if i knew
there was at least a path that's my
thing
but like yeah because because the the
other thing is that like some people
don't really care about seals and i'm
one of those guys like and the reason i
don't care about seals is just because
the
the effort versus reward is so off
balance like
it's like oh do an entire raid with
everyone in void subclass and i'm just
like
it's tedious it's like all right i gotta
get six people in i gotta make sure that
they've all got the thing okay we're
gonna do it this time and then like i
won't do that but if you would have told
me that i could have avoided doing 80
uh raids on uh deep stone crypt to get
isaac tomorrow i would have done it
because that would have been way too
easy with my time so yeah i just think
that there needs to be like a high
threshold where you can force it to drop
and then a low threshold where you can
just get lucky or just keep doing it and
and that's more interesting because yeah
it the the hurt is real like i i was
doing isa tomorrow until the season
after eyes of tomorrow which i think was
this season wow i think i got it the
weak vaulted glass dropped that was the
week i finally got eyes of tomorrow so
it was like that's painful like yeah the
the worst possible situation yep yeah
that sucks okay
sorry for the detour no no you're good
you're good it was a fun one uh fighting
lion they said this wasn't a specific
problem but given the increased
frustration with bridge grenade
launchers and crucible seemed like a
missed up to say hey we hear you and
here's also an infinite version of the
thing that frustrated you
so they did some tweaking to it but
people feel like fighting line got
knocked down too far
so they said they require remove the
multi-hit requirement for the perk to
proc dealing damage any damage will
grant the buff the buff
increased the buff reload stat from plus
50 to plus 70.
so the rear wheel reload will be slow if
you miss but if you land any damage
fighting line will reload faster than it
did before the nerf and they also
increased the buff duration to seven
seconds so a little more manageable
hopefully still not quite as crazy
oppressive for fighting line with you
know the ammo that it's got but
generally
it was kind of nerfed
yeah
am i that'll be interesting am i reading
this wrong so i'm not i'm not a big
fighting lion guy i haven't really
removed the multi-hit requirement so
they're making it so instead of having
to do multiple sources of damage or
multiple damage you just have to do one
one damage of like one take right any
damage will give the buff looks right
yeah that looks like that's a buff to
the gun right yeah that's a buff
increasing the buff to the reload speed
from plus 50 to plus 70. so you reload
faster that's a buff
right and then you increase the buff
duration where's the nerf
so the nerf is the ammo it's not going
to be infinite ammo oh wait did they say
it's not infinite is it not yeah so this
is because they say that
there's still a difference between
almost infinite ammo and actually
infinite ammo and how weapons are used
and in play tests where we tried to
abuse infant ammo is extraordinarily
oppressive much more so than we expected
given it had a ton of ammo previously
yeah so they're like i think they're
what they're saying is that
when they tested it with all ammo people
were just shooting it recklessly because
they knew they had infinite ammo but if
they give it a finite ammo even if it's
a lot people are um more cautious with
it because fighting lion and pvp is kind
of one of those guns you shoot around
corners and you're kind of just like
taking shots in the dark until you get
lucky and hit something and then you
like rush in you know so i think i think
it's not going to have infinite ammo is
the way i read that uh that blurb shout
out to the homie scarole up in here i
was scared
how you doing he said it was yeah man
what's up he said it was previously
nerfed this is a slight buff to undo
some of the changes with the previous
nerf nice
so is it going to have infinite ammo
they're saying for sure
i
honestly can't quite tell the perk by
the way is thin the herd i'll read it
for you guys direct hits do more damage
to combatant shields damaging multiple
combatants and this is where the changes
come in increases reload speed rapidly
defeating grenade damage combatants
refills the magazine
so if you hit like multiple and you kill
multiple basically you're in almost
instantly refilled is where it can be
really cool but
yeah okay
i said yeah i just i just don't know the
gun very well it's just yeah i mean yeah
i don't use i don't know it's like fun
at times
i've had fun goofing around with it at
times but it was like i mean in grenade
launchers it was fun to mess with but
usually there's a reason to put some
other exotic on besides it most of the
time yeah for sure i love that gun i
never i never use it but i always have
somebody on my team who does because
it's just so funny though then they
honestly they just shoot it it's like
sending canaries in a coal mine they're
just like let's see if they're over
there and they'll just like shoot it
down the hole oh i got a hit let's run
down there
i do like yeah after the whole
mountaintop grind i still do
enjoy using sleeper or not sleeper um
salvagers
i may not be the best but i'm probably
an annoying person with my breach loads
if i start getting some decent shots or
god you're better the occasional direct
hit like they did bring them down a
little bit but man if i get the direct
hits those do feel good because they
don't happen that often be like oh
thanks yeah you took a grenade to the
chest you also should be dead
anyway arbalist now has intrinsic
anti-barrier i am so happy about this
it's not even funny yeah it's huge it's
gonna be huge for your videos huh
uh you lost sector videos
oh i mean it's just gonna be like
especially for the next three months
like when you go into take a grand
master anti-barrier paired with particle
deconstruction it's kind of perfect
honestly
so i'm really looking forward because i
think we were messing around in um
literally
proving grounds grand master i was
working on with new red and black wings
and i was like i took rb in because it
still is good to get that pair and we
had all the shields covered but it's
like if this had barrier right now i
wouldn't even need an auto rifle and i
could just have any other variety in
there it would just be so nice so now
i'm looking and the with the shield
breaking that it does no this
this is with the 10
anti with the 10 buff yeah this is gonna
be good oh so excited for this because
to be honest when arboles debuted
this is what i envisioned it to be
for end game content especially with the
shield breaking and the in the damage so
i'm like yes this is what i'm talking
about and then another because there's
not a lot of anti-barrier exotics
besides um
pretty much the only one right so yeah
let's let's do it let's get our glass
where it needs to be always gonna be
nice next season man that's a great look
i like this one big time yeah i've been
growing on linears and seeing these buff
it's nice to see if they get a little
more speaking of linears
sleeper simulant cognito's favorite his
baby is getting a little extra buff
so along with ten percent buff from
above and they say in parenthesis really
this time because last time they tried
this they killed it
we've given it some additional love so
the magazine is up from three to four
which is big because that thing has
always been a substantial piece and
increased pve damage another 16 so it's
getting 16 total damage buff
um coming on the coming with everything
else that already was kind of broken and
then fixed
lament as anti-barrier that is the other
one i totally forgot i never think about
that one yeah forget about lament
i forgot about that yeah this is big man
this is big shout out to the cops going
by they agree um three to four um on
that inc on the reload i mean on the on
the mag it's huge i was just doing riven
with dj and those guys
and it kind of annoyed me that reed's
regret was a better option with vorpal
and you know i said i had a little bit
more and i believe a clown cartridge and
i'm just like
to put sleep away just felt wrong yeah
you know what i mean it's an exotic it
should be yeah
you know leading that category in some
aspect yeah i like the magazine size and
the damage then you throw that on top of
the linear
sleeper boys we lit man i'm good i'm
good let's keep it going keep it going i
love it nice
soros regime the dual mode receiver
basically where it turns it into a high
impact auto rifle will now grant the
following in addition to its current
effects it's going to give plus 30 range
and three zoom
basically this is going to be a beast of
a high impact auto rifle
or you can go fast mode with it which is
still going to be good but it's going to
make both options substantially
different and the slow one didn't feel
great before now i think it's actually
going to be pretty stout
do you guys agree disagree
thoughts that could be good yeah
sure i don't really use the gun that
much uh been a while it is kind of nice
that um service is definitely like uh
working with this game ever since
ever since d1 yeah recognizable guns so
i think it's gonna be really cool seeing
some more service regimes in pvp
in the coming months
i don't really see it being a top tier
pick or anything but i mean it's nice to
got some love because this gun has been
in desperate need of it for a very very
long time it's just not the best well
especially that mode especially that
moment
the slow mode is just
not it man it's just not it not it
try anesthesia 77k
given the state of stasis in pvp at the
start of season 14 we deliberately ship
this weapon in a weak state
which almost hurts us but it was the
right direction and i get it but also it
really sucks when you know they're like
hey this weapon's crap here you go
most like i still haven't gone back for
my other 22
uh
crucible kills with that that's just
staring at me i'm like i don't want to
do it
maybe
i don't want to but maybe now i will i i
liked that gun i got my masterwork and
then kept using it so really i'm
interested to see if it how good it gets
with uh
yeah i mean it was weaker but yeah
sidearms are just in a good place in
general right now yeah it's all good so
they have reworked it to address its
weakness in pve probably gonna feel good
across the board though specifically the
following pain point fire on release
with charge trigger losing all ammo on
the freezing shot so
it was weird to fire too on top of
everything else it's just a little odd
uh removed variable trigger completely
now fires on trigger press instead of
release which will make it feel much
more responsive
charge shot move to special reload
getting a final blow at the sidearm
enables access to the special shot so
you just reload you switch over and you
have that free shot once the charge shot
is fired the weapon reverts back to
standard sidearm mode this does not cost
your entire magazine
charge shot now causes an aoe which
freezes ai and slows players direct hits
will still freeze overall it sounds like
this is what the gun hopefully should
have shipped like because it feels like
it's gonna work a bit more functionally
as we know other things do and i'm
honestly looking forward to it
aoe they say
uh yeah so maybe it will shoot the
ground at a control point and actually
get a little uh slow down buff and slow
him down
i can see true vanguard putting in some
work he's a sidearm guy
yeah you rock this rapping trap what you
think
yeah i like it um i think uh
we'll see we'll see like the main
complaint with the gun i think more than
like its effect for stasis was its feel
it's a little bit of a sloppier sidearm
like it's not as straight shooting and
it kind of has like a very like
distinctive like floaty feeling to you
yeah like shooting something with like a
out of control firehose
a little bit
yeah but uh i don't know it could be
good i i don't know if i'll put it back
on like it's not going to be part of the
meta this season just because vex method
class exists and stuff but in the future
i think it might be a good one to have
in your back pocket especially if
sidearms continue to be as
relevant as they are
next one we got leviathan's breath and
swifty feel free to chime in on any of
these so i'm just kind of working
through them i'll jump i'm jumping on
that one
yeah i'm gonna jump in on this one yeah
i gotta love you after you got to you i
got that one too
breath this bow is under use chucking
so we wanted to give it a bump and while
also making its catalyst more
interesting expects this type of
catalyst tweaked to become more common
moving forward the catalyst now grants
the archer's tempo perk in addition to
other effects somebody want to remind
for one me and also chat what does the
catalyst do for this thing
is it deeper reserves i have it i
believe it's just deeper reserves it's
deeper yeah it gives you more arrows
yeah it's a very weird catalyst
yeah
inventory size and i was disappointed
yeah i'm sorry i far i farmed for that
thing during the season of the hunt and
i was just like
this is
not a good exotic that was like the
thing that stuck out to me the most
because i was just like i i can't think
of any reason i would use this it's like
it's unstoppable
i haven't and that's their cat
their catalyst solution was just to give
you more of it i'm like oh cool now i
get more of a bad exotic like i don't
you know it was a really weird move
excellent swifty oh i was gonna jump all
you know
oh i wouldn't have read that loves this
exactly
i'm one of the five people i'm raising
my hand with the five um yo all right
it it's it's slow as balls it we get it
it hits like a truck i am curious with
archer's tempo with the dps how that's
gonna go because it's just that it hits
as hard as anything it's just so damn
slow i just like the fact that it's void
because i don't really feel like i have
a lot of good it's like a high impact
fusion rifle now that it feels like it
takes an hour to charge those things
exactly outside of like
deathbringer you know my void heavy
options always feel eliminated and i
like to be honest i do like the
intrinsic unstoppable where i don't have
to you know necessarily mod up
on you know arms for something else if
it's not the um
you know artifact unstoppable for the
season you know what i'm saying kind of
thing like the fact that they added it
so they've been trying i'm with trav
though
catalyst was wacky just added like
another bullet or whatever that for all
the effort they made you do that that
that was weak but i'm willing to see
what this what it does you know all five
of us is clapping in this room for it so
you know i respect that i respect it
shout out to team devices
swifty are you for against do you even
care about this thing oh this is this is
the best thing in the club
oh damn
this is unironically probably the thing
i'm most excited about
to you to find this front let's go ahead
and you got six now you got a whole fire
team you gotta go let me get let me get
you a contract brother let me get you a
contract
my contract's going to end really soon
because the reason why i want it is um
we might agree on the gun we probably
don't agree on where it's good for let's
go okay
break it
this is down
gambit invasion weapon
oh break it down break it down this is a
gambit invasion weapon
because
when you have wall hacks
the downside of drawing around the
corner
does not exist and to make it better
if you can sustain your ammo economy
this is a sniper that body shot supers
savage
this um uh just for perspective um one
of my friends um
and clan mates in a gambinocrine family
uh his name is ironically bad
last season
this guy grinded out one million
seasonal infamy
that's an absurd that's like what
go outside and see some grass i go
outside in the season
and um
he's an invader main in the only weapon
he uses he uses a succession
because high zoom snipers are better in
gambit due to the size of the playing
field nope
and the leviathan's breath
he has 5 000 kills in his leviathan's
breath what zero of those were gained in
a pvp match those are invasion kills oh
my god
bro that is it you're telling me that
body shot's a super
yeah
wow
told y'all yeah
some things have a little bit too much
so some things have a little bit too
much resistance um obviously but
it's crazy it's really [ __ ] oh this
is so toxic let's go it's really good
and so i'm gonna i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you a little secret about
invading efficiently in gambit
oh this is where the gambit love comes
into play hold on
love discussion right here scarole on
the other hand wants to kick you out of
the podcast but that's a different thing
of course
he knows
yourself get it
the best setups to invade with let's go
generally speaking
superstars are the ones that take the
least amount of skill possible
that lead and also lead the highest
results there's a reason why people will
invade with a golden gun
because that is the freest army of one
you've ever used
leviathan's breath takes the most
minimalistic amount of skill possible
and it yields the highest result of any
other gun that you could possibly use
above eyes of tomorrow
it is more effective to use than eyes of
tomorrow
yeah that is true and that was a good
game again
this this gun ah
i hate playing against this gun it is so
good let's move it over for my damn
right now keep talking the first time
my friend messaged me i'm going to bring
up this long
flavor text i love how somebody called
out scarole and chad he's like aren't
you guilded dredging times three because
he's
cause he's a completionist he has every
triumph and everything
see no he's playing that
playing that gambit
hilarious i sent my friend ironically
the bungie twablic and he said
no shots
holy [ __ ] bundy does not know what they
have just equipped me with
i'm never going into gambit ever again
because if i face it it's already over
it is unholy what he's going to do with
archer's temple on the wyathensburg
i am so excited to see the clips
uh it is
genuinely mind-blowing but anyway
i'm a gambit lover i went on my little
tangent i love leviathan's breath i
think it's a super cool and unique
weapon
i think this buff is really nice i think
this gun will probably forever be
irrelevant in pve and pvp
but obviously because a lot of people
don't really play gambit they don't
understand the strengths of using this
weapon while invading
and uh
yeah i think this
this gun is going to be even crazier
than it already is now it's going to be
so interesting to play against this i
might i'm an invader man i'm probably
going to have to pick this thing up
do you have any thoughts about this
whole ridiculous discussion we're having
right now
[Laughter]
i think i just was on a different plane
for 10 minutes
shattered realm yeah
all right well shout out to uh an annex
unfortunately shout out to him yeah me
too um just not guilted
i did that once but shout out to an
unexpected discussion about velocin's
breath
yes yes my turn
whoo
whisper oh the worm the original dps
king has fallen out of favor uh-huh
with the delay before the damage buff
kicking into making sure the weapon is
less usable in short game damage phases
and optimal sustained damage requiring
all critical shots but not sufficiently
rewarding precision
so
i don't know if this is going to make it
like god tier
but all i can say is
brother this is all you come on all i
can say is like every one of these
changes are good reduces the delay of
activating whispering breath from the
catalyst from 2.1 to 1.2 it's almost
twice as fast to get there
uh a white nail magazine refill changed
it was pulling from inventory constantly
now only two of the three bullets come
from inventory so 33 of your you know
free for 33 of your refill is freebies
so that's also gonna make your reserves
much deeper
yeah actually i like that if you can hit
all three you get one for free it's not
bad and increase pde damage by ten
percent so you got a lot more deep ammo
reserves you can hit those crits and
keep a white nail going 10 damage bonus
and as you're refilling whispering
breath comes up much quicker which will
keep that damage higher all in all
they're all good changes i don't know if
it's gonna like you know like knock
linear fusion rifles off of their
particle deconstruction right now but
depending on what happens in the witch
queen stuff like that
definitely it's a held a lot better than
it used to be for sure
so i'm happy to see that i just gotta
ask you a question so
this is this is your baby this is it's
one of your biggest
videos or your chat like this gun
anymore sadly
the activity to get it's not there but
yeah exactly so what's the funny thing i
was thinking about you know what if
there is a a bow
deconstruction behind next season with
leviathan's breath
as much as i love bows i'd be okay with
that what if it's a bull artifact next
season y'all dude it's crazy i love most
i'd be totally happy about that i love
both like
when they announced bows for destiny i
was like
i could not wrap my head around it
but of course if they're gonna put
something into a game bungie does know
how to make weapons feel correct
so and when i pulled the bow and fired
it i was like damn it now granted our
arrows are like tracking curveballs
depending on what you're firing at
because if you've ever fired a bow at a
pve enemy where its head is behind a
wall
you have to like pull so far out to like
hit their toe because it hooks so hard
but no i love both like yeah if you give
me a bow
they will do it or a sniper
deconstruction equivalent
it's going to be a fun season
some new red saying whisper plus
divinity is just going to be clip-worthy
yeah it's like you could put divinity on
and just smash the current spot all day
yeah it's going to be fun speaking of
that you've got another option as well
darcy
this sniper rifles damage has fallen
behind as other options have been buffed
uh-huh snipers yeah you knock them down
and all i can say is all of the sniper
knockdowns were because please don't sit
in the back of the back of the map and
shoot these bosses that stand still i'm
like you made the bosses that way
i wish they would make
i guess there's this is like a point in
a swift i'm kind of curious because like
you've played been playing since destiny
1.
and
they went from
valles to arik
the perpetual meme sit in the back of
the room hit him in the head from far
away two
you never get to stand still in the
circular arena because things chase you
around but yet you do occasionally have
raid bosses like that is there i wish
they would get a little more to me not
and also please don't do just shield
phases i wish they would do mechanics
for some of these like strike bosses
because i the whole running around and
doing just like you you can't get
touched and stuff like that like shield
brothers was always a bit of a nightmare
it was a fun guide to make but a bit of
a nightmare but it's like
some of these
are always it's weird because you have
the they started in destiny one where
you could sit in the back and then they
really don't want you to sit in the back
anymore so they made everything like
utter chaos
and then somewhere i wish they just
would put mechanics in the middle of
that to make it a bit more manageable
but still give you some cover
any thoughts on just kind of where some
of the bosses are in destiny at this
point because the snipers didn't exist
for the longest time literally because
of how the bosses were made
yeah that's true boss design has always
been a point of contention um
my personal favorite bosses um are ones
that require you to be active during a
damage phase so scourge the pass boss
definitely um instruction prime stands
out where you have to move between the
circles
um i think that's pretty good boss
design um
unfortunately a lot of the bosses
um like even like atheon uh
you put down a well and then everybody
kind of just congregates together
and um you don't move and you just like
look down your scope and shoot them
uh
and i like that atheon moves
templar doesn't move
the heartbeat moved backwards in garden
i love the harpy and garden because
being forced to push forward is actually
push yeah i think that's a really cool
thing and that also makes shotguns a lot
harder to use in close range options
though we have one phase in with a sword
anyway
um
yeah uh
generally speaking as far as boss design
goes um i want a boss
that's like i have to do damage while
the boss is running around and summoning
fire pits under my feet and then he's
also like blinking side to side around
an arena like i want
i don't like the idea of having an ad
phase or a mechanic phase and then a
boss damage phase i want it all to kind
of be congregated in one i like the
hectic situations i like it where you
can't just sit down in a well and
breathe and just shoot your shots off
with like no danger of repercussions i
like activity being being more active in
a boss fight
um stuff like x's crash is really cool
um unfortunately um
he can't really kill you through a wall
uh even on gm that well so yeah
you gotta just sit there um i think well
of radiance is
a very big problem that trivializes the
game in a lot of different aspects
i think boss design would be better
without it
but
that's that's an entire discussion for
another day
the support classes yeah i don't hear
what you're saying i think um
darcy definitely needed this like it's
darcy been in the bushes so so hard like
i don't even know what laughs
even say what it had coming for it hold
on oh i'm sorry no i totally forgot i
was just like a darcy and then we got
off on the other one but uh basically
they reduced the flinch recoil and
accuracy degradation by 50 while
personal assistant is active which is if
you have the highlight on our target it
basically gives you 4x damage i think
it's 4x
personal assistant now has a one second
delay before deactivating one off a
target so if you do get flinched you can
get it back on it will stay as opposed
to being instantly off and then it
increased the damage in pve by 20
now somebody remind me is darcy the one
that can have like 28 in reserves or
something saying like its reserves are
really deep yeah okay really really deep
reserves
so again just chewed through ammo but it
was uh it was good dps people used to
use it um for a scourge that was the
last time it got used was first courage
boss
i got a boat i'm sorry i'll let you
finish
oh no i'm done uh
oh i got this job what did i say no i i
got a bone and pick not with darcy
though now with darcy um
i'm looking out at all this uh beautiful
sniper love and i'm saying darcy well
deserved you know what i'm saying i'm
saying whisper well deserve
but my man skyrow is in here and he
should know
there is one sniper that we all raided
together with where's my izanagi burton
man
what's going on bro what's up with izzy
i like izzy it's a special and they're
afraid of making it too powerful as much
it's too dangerous to be kept alive if
izzy's good no other sniper can be good
easy though
i love that gun it had its heyday and it
has been buried
come on
give us the reload glitch back
bro we did that we did that with that
guarded bro we what's megatron the the
floating dude all right i love this
event that was that's the first that's
great one of the few raids we did
together
scarole took us through that one i
remember that we did it literally right
after he was on the podcast we got to
get you back on here scarole seriously
yeah foreign hair sophisticated
professor man in here now and you got to
come with your guitar and you got to
play the um queenswalk theme song that's
mandatory when you come back yeah that's
the send off for the podcast yeah well
you do that
yeah i need
yeah um yeah izzy's buried for a while
i'm sure it's not changing uh
malfeasance uh for a weapon all about
explosions this hand cannons explosions
were a bit underwhelming increased the
damage by 50
somebody also said they were wondering
if this was gonna work with lucky pants
but they said potentially not so i don't
know if that's gonna be broken or not
but i'm sure
hopefully they thought about it we'll
see
dead man's tail they said they've seen
the scout rifle usage dropped
dramatically on consoles since the
recent nerf so we spent some time tuning
in a way that benefits controller more
than mouse and keyboard basically they
increased reticle friction fall off
distance less recoil and improved
accuracy
and these effects should not affect
mouse and keyboard so hopefully helping
controller players
because i know in on pc it's toxic like
it's been bad for a while it's still
there like it still hits me sometimes
even in my mediocre pvp matches but yeah
if controller never got to live it up a
little bit and it got hit harder
probably needs a little love just to be
able to be usable
this one i am not surprised if you've
been marching enough around in trials a
little bit air appearance catalyst they
reduce the damage resistance against
players from 75
to 25 brick
i read that and i was i'm like no wonder
you're a walking tank holy crap dude do
a little bit of trolling
i'm walking about yeah dude you're just
walking you're just like
oh
the heavy ammo it's over it's over
suddenly trials turns into juggernaut
yeah
if you ever play that halo mode it's fun
man
it's it's so toxic i like it
it's just you can't
you can't kill
oh my god hold on i have a clip
i need to show you i need to show this
clip since we're talking about air
apparent you won't be able to show it
here but yeah i found it i found it i
found that i found it i'm going to put
this in the chat yeah just put it in the
chat
yeah man like that's it
steve a good riddance heir apparent
literally the super chat of toy dollars
he's super chatted the good origins he
hates the damn
yeah you've been having some struggles
there siva got to get that apple pie
toast crunch get yourself another bowl i
know you found some
listen
i go front like i used to feel like all
those [ __ ] like terminated too just
like dude you're unstoppable with that
when you hear that thing revving up you
hear somebody coming it's not like a
truck
yeah you're just like oh god
yeah man just just watch the clip that's
all you gotta do just watch the clip
it's so bad
please just watch the clip
oh wow yeah wow here i'll copy it
because i can probably put it in the
chat you might not be able to hardly i
already beat you there nice nice footage
yeah
wow it's just not fair like are you
kidding me with that really i love it i
love it
it was a good ride it was a good one
well deserved nerf but uh
it was fun man it was a fun life if
while it lasted
here new red put this in chat because my
mind's being all weird yeah yeah
link that up in chat yeah real quick
because i know we skipped over but shout
out to about the malfeasy
i want to see them explosion damage i
think that's it because that gun needed
it man that hand can't need to do
something fifty percent yeah that's good
i wanna see if if we getting like
sunshine flow like what we getting i
wanna see that action you know what i'm
saying yeah i wish you could put
something like dragonfly on that too
just to make it even more expressive
just
if you're warlock
oh i know if you're a warlock you get to
have a little extra fun
don't throw a certain little jacket on
chromatic fire yeah throw that little
jacket on let's see you see what that
malfuzi really do
[Laughter]
yeah
you you you guys in your warlocks anyway
lauren strategy that's concerning uh
this kind of lawrence driver starts like
a piece where they're actually kind of
talking about a direction they're trying
to take things they said the bonus
ability energy feels extraneous when the
damage buff is so strong so we're
limited limiting certain weapon sources
of ability energy and they mentioned in
previous swabs they're trying to get pvp
away from ability spam more towards
gunfights and it seems like there's
multiple things going to that
both of the next two kind of touch on
that one so they removed ability energy
regeneration on picking up a telemetry
telemetry is still going to do the
damage buff and whatever else it does
but you're just not getting the ability
energy as well so they're not trying to
have it basically spam abilities all the
time along with everything else it does
travelers chosen on a similar aspect the
ability energy granted from this perk
was on a curve that isn't intuitively
understood similar to lawrence driver it
seemed appropriate to adjust this in pvp
the changes aren't noticeable in pvp pve
they said it now grants a 10 ability
energy per stack on activation it was
previously more generous on low stacks
less generous on high stacks so instead
of being really high and then sloping
down and being less useful for the high
end more of a linear stacking buff that
you're going to get out of it which
makes sense like if you there should be
a reason to go for the high stack as
opposed to just keep it low and go
uh they also reduce the stacks granted
on a guardian defeat from three to two
so it's gonna be a little harder to get
those stacks up there if you can go for
a five stack more power to you but it
will be harder to do
uh final thing we've got is perks
and then we'll have our nice little wrap
up to get out of here
um couple perks though they did mention
adrenaline junkie was gonna get a change
finally broke it down eliminations with
the weapon
can add single damage stacks or extend
existing ones grenade elimination boosts
the stack immediately to 5x kind of the
way um
yep it's basically grenade swashbuckling
grenade
is grenade and then lower the duration
to compensate for weapon activation so
won't be active as long but you will be
getting it more frequently
yeah any thoughts yay good anybody got
any i likes it good yeah
it's about as it's about what everybody
thought it was going to be to be honest
i think it's a good change nice
adrenaline junkie previously was a
pretty
meh perk very mad i think changing it to
be uh spongebob grenades is actually
really good facts i dismantled that
thing as soon as i seen it on any gun i
have
i don't even have it in a jelly joker i
had i had like a couple and then
like i think one was in my postmaster
and literally the tweet came out from
dng i'm like oh i'll save it
that's why my vault's always full
because i'm insane like that but
uh vorpal weapon speaking of your reed's
regret making sleeper look even better
now
a perk that grants 15 bonus damage
against all targets i'm gonna use my
heavy weapon on
seems like a non-choice and suck the air
out of the room for other damage perks
at the same time it was failing its
original role giving players a reason to
run a primary weapon against tough
targets so it was 15 on everything now
on heavies it's 10
specials is 15 primaries is 20 percent
on the same targets because you got
champions bosses vehicles and guardians
and supers i think are the four
no change to damage for super players
though
so you still be able to get the benefit
in pvp that you had before on
any weapon apparently whatever you're
going to use it on but they are trying
to lean into vorpal allowing primaries
to do 20 more damage to
bosses basically which in theory gives
you a little more flexibility granted a
sword is still going to smash the crap
out of like the prophecy boss but still
50 quick question do you think with this
15 percent
going it went down from on heavy right
it went down from was it 15 to 10. yeah
so
the question i have for you guys because
i don't know the numbers um
does that now made the reed regret
linear with firing line more sexier
versus vorpal down
uh well
reid's regret is a heavy weapon so
verbal weapon goes down to 10 percent
which is less than the buff the firewall
gives you yeah so fire line become yeah
granted firing line is definitely harder
to activate true right i'm just talking
about like boss dps type phases
i definitely think it would be the more
worthwhile perk uh 100
okay fan now fan enough yeah uh i will
say on this topic though um
i think it's
it's it's really interesting um
so obviously every single weapon and
they mention this in the description
um every single weapon
type kind of has its role uh with
primaries you're meant to shoot them
mainly just against like ads like red
bars um
special weapons
are more for like your champions or your
majors or your ultras or kind of
kind of a little bit tougher enemies
a little bit of health bar heavy weapons
are more for bosses than champions uh
i think
nerfing vorpal on heavy weapons
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
in the same category that i think
buffing it on primaries doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
because
you're trying to incentivize using a
perk
to do a role that it's not meant to do
or could be done efficiently otherwise
so like here's a great example um
verbal is great on primaries as like an
anti-barrier weapon
but i wouldn't use it against overload
champions because i'm going to stun the
overload and then i'm going to use not
that weapon correct right exactly you're
going to delete that guy quickly as
possible you're not just going to kind
of plank them down with 5 more bonuses
yeah if the expectation is that i'm
supposed to continue to shoot my primary
weapon at the champion
i think that's kind of just misguided as
to how it actually plays out in a real
situation because nobody's just
primarying down a champion you know like
it's just
it seems like a little bit
asinine i guess like it's just not not
where it needs to be it's yeah i
understand why they do it
but i think their intentions are
misguided here at valid point yeah
completely i'm not i'm not gonna go do
boss damage with the scout rifle just
because more than it's not they're
trying to make it
more variety
in the sense that you can use whatever
weapon you want to mm-hmm but
we're coming full circle
with double primaries
changing this perk doesn't actually do
what i think they're intending it to do
what it does is it lets a scout rifle
break a barrier shield faster what it
doesn't do is incentivize people to
shoot the scout rifle at the champion
after the shield is broken
so they've essentially made better
champion mods
but
i'm just not really feeling this change
personally i don't think it's going to
change
it's not going to bring the the effect
that they wanted to no yeah i think it's
it's like
you know fool's goal to try to make it
seem like they give they're truly giving
you something else after the real
intention was to nerf vorpal heavy
that's what this is yeah that's how i
looked at it they came in they're like
look this is the the de facto perk on
heavy for legendaries and we got to do
something about it oh yeah we're going
to give you primary and energy but again
like you said practical usage it's it's
not there i'm with you on that big time
city yep
whirlwind blade uh was too obviously the
best sword perk around so while we're
fine with it being good at sustained
damage we've pulled back for shorter
fights so they increased the number of
stacks needed to hit maximum damage from
5 to 10 so it is going to take longer
for whirlwind blade to actually stack
all the way up to its full potential um
than it did before so if you sit there
and wail on like say profit prophecy
boss like the first boss you sit there
and everybody uses a sword on him
whether you're solo or anything just
you're gonna nuke him with a sword it's
just gonna take a little longer to get
whirlwind but at that point it just
makes relentless strikes even that more
potent personally
i don't know about anybody else
tragic
yeah i love swordsman um the sword
rework is
ever since the sword rework happened
i've just been a huge sword guy um i
think roland blade was a great perk i
think it was definitely like the only
applicable perk for its slot on like
basically every single legendary sword
uh
getting this nerf kind of hurts uh
because you're severely damaging the
amount of dps it can output
with its best option
uh which sucks i mean it does suck um
but i'm okay with this i don't i don't
think it's that big of a deal i think uh
swords will still live
yeah so it's just i don't know it's not
exactly the direction i'd like to see
maybe buff some alternative perks vorpal
weapon being added to the category uh
stuff like throne cleaver is really
really nice too or just a flat 15 even
though it's much less than a whirlwind's
total
provides better dps in short term just
because it ramps up immediately yep
similar to kind of vorpal versus frenzy
yeah that regarding like bose
uh
it's it's it's a nerf i mean it happens
i it's not the end of the world for
swords but it's a little bit
disappointing not gonna lie or is it
it might be this one nerf might just
kill the whole
we'll have your salon it's the straw
that breaks the swords back
uh this one i'm probably gonna go for
some of the technical expertise for chat
and also probably use swifty pulse
monitor because in theory this actually
does sound promising
what if instead of activating on it when
it feels like a fail state this
activated on a state would you'll be in
in almost every encounter even if you're
winning so they said they changed the
threshold for pulse monitor activation
from 90 health
to
30 shield this now requires much less
damage to trigger
so somebody explained me and i could be
totally crazy my understanding your
health bar is basically broken up into
kind of a third and two-thirds
two-thirds is basically your shield
bottom third is kind of your health is
that relatively close swifty
kind of
uh
yeah um
i'm i don't know the real science of
this more than you do uh to be honest
i'm not sure what it sounds like they're
doing is without breaking your shield
like if you get shot once in the head
with the hand cannon versus twice in the
head with the hand cannon yep this would
activate um pretty much which
definitely makes sense um pulse monitor
overall though
and i'm just
ah it's a little bit of a lackluster
perk yeah
reloads weapon improves weapon handling
improved weapon handling is very very
good
very very good um in this current
sandbox especially around shotguns but
the better perk in that category that's
being uh not really slept on because
people are discovering it with sudden
death it's threat detector threat
detector does pulse monitor yeah but
instead of having to get damaged you
just have to be next to something
proximity
so
it's just
pretty definitively the better version
of this perk
um
i think it's nice the pulse monitor got
that buff
uh
i i just still wouldn't pick it
personally i don't know that's fair it's
better than it was but still may not be
great
yeah better than i was still trav still
might not be the greatest trav you were
shaking your head
um yeah i i think uh
so sorry uh i kind of got off on
something else the this is the one where
it doesn't start affecting you until
later in years basically until you're in
you're right like until your screen
flashes red basically is when you're in
your health bar and now it's going to be
while you're shooting it's almost looks
like almost like where you'd almost be
50 is about where that would be 30 of
your shield left i i i kind of just feel
like um all of the circumstantial
uh where you or you have to be in a very
specific
situation to help you out like i feel
like those ones are always going to lose
to just the general yeah across the
board like makes you better at this
always you've killed something you do 10
more damage well i understand how that
works all the time
as opposed to you have to be at 90 of
your health within four meters of this
guy over here with the x factor yeah
or the surrounded spec one it's like oh
if you're on venus and there's three
drags around here
you know one one one of them has
recently had a child then you'll do like
40 more damage it's like all right
i'm not even gonna be thinking about
that when i'm in like a raid so maybe
just like give me more ammo or something
you know that's how i feel about it yeah
fair enough yeah we look i'm what would
you guys you know i'm still not going to
pick this it's a it's a buff but
still not an exciting one enough for me
to make that a de facto pick
not all perks can be god mode perks
apparently some are just not going to be
as good
as for mods they did change up a couple
of them uh quick access sling said the
usage on this mod is very telling it's
extensively used with bows and breech
grenade launchers and barely used at all
on any other weapons why
um basically it's for finishing up
something that you basically you know
nearly kill whether you hit him with a
bow switch the hand cannon one tap or
hit him with a grenade launcher switch
one tap it's pretty much all it's used
for
now i don't know the technical specs
here they said it was plus 100 handling
comma 0.9 times the ready stow aim down
sights time for .4 seconds after running
out of ammo
it's a cute wonderful understand if you
got all that more power to you and then
now it's just the 0.9 times the ready
stow time all the time said this change
also applies to the swap mag perk as
they use the same perk behind the scenes
this one's interesting uh because if you
think about it they said in the
beginning it's extensively used on bose
and breach grenade launchers
that is because bows and breech grenade
launchers have one ammo in the magazine
yep and so the second that you fire them
it is beneficial to swap away from them
as far as quick access sling goes
this is
really just a mod that's used for people
who want to use two weapons really fast
or the toxic quick swappers with uh you
know ariana's vow bow
uh
grenade launcher into like a hand cannon
that kind of like prime and finish style
yep or you shoot off your one shot
weapon hit him with a second and then uh
go on your merry way i hate playing
against people like this in uh
in pvp i
i got on my my free to play alt account
um
to start my unbroken grinds
for the season
in my first game i faced two people
lee monarch steady hand bow swapping
that was the only game of comp i played
that night
i didn't i did not go back in after that
and
yeah maybe we just give up on this uh
i hated this mod uh it is useful
literally nowhere else but to be toxic
in pvp i'm really happy that this
happened it sucks for the people who
like play this play style but at the
same time i really don't [ __ ] respect
this place so i'm totally cool with this
guy
this is like
beyond the stag rifting in my opinion
this is this is true
creatures that's your mouthguard
i mean
we got some basement dwellers on this
one
so
um especially with the quick draw glitch
now being gone this is kind of just like
an
outlier that needed to be hit as well if
bungie wanted to reduce the handling
kind of across the board um and so it
was a little bit unfair that people
couldn't like
shoot a shotgun and then go to their
hand kitten really quickly but
um it was more beneficial to do so with
bows and breached grenade launchers and
you don't actually lose any benefit from
it because other mods aren't as
impactful
on those weapons in pvp
as they would be on another weapon um
overall i just think this is this is
really good man
unfortunately
they kind of killed the mod because they
made they turned it from being useful
for these two particular archetypes and
weapons to being useful for these zero
particular types of architecture exactly
just delete the mod it doesn't see ya
just delete them all they just need to
get rid of that
that's their that's their deletions of
the game they're going to sunset two
things for the 30th anniversary
yeah
celesto telesto's the linchpin for all
the bungee code for destiny if they
delete to lester they'll delete that's
probably the only reason it's still in
the game otherwise they would have
probably deleted it a long time ago
that i think somebody said telesco was
the most expensive weapon they have ever
made and i was like for the amount of
effort the devs have put in trying to
fix what it has broken that gun has cost
more than probably literally anything
else probably do a big margin it's the
uh
it's the sabbath of the destiny
always leading them astray
yeah leading them astray it's it's it's
uh letting it's the domino that uh
started it all
i've done uh final one is full auto
retrofit uh they're doing this for
accessibility basically um
they're to allow you to basically have a
full auto
mod i think it seems like that enables
full auto while the trigger is held it's
usable on legendary hand cannons sidearm
scout rifles and pulse rifles uh this
will be unlocked defaults for all
players yep everybody gets that mod so
if you want something to be full auto
yeah what do you think
interesting i don't like it
i think spicy accessibility option is
great
i think the way they went about it is
bad
because
you have to sacrifice something yes yeah
if we're talking about an accessibility
option i think in the in the same league
as fast ball and traction this should be
a game play setting something like auto
fire single shot weapons as a game play
setting i don't know how realistic that
is
but when i think i can either have the
ease of access to shoot my gun faster or
lose 7.7 damage aka a spec mod
in pve or lose icarus grip or lose a
beneficial
factor that could be on my gun
to sacrifice that for the accessibility
doesn't seem like a trade-off i should
be forced to make no
that i actually completely agree with
because i know some people don't want
full auto to be
a free thing because some people like
somebody's saying vigilance swing
doesn't really matter and that's i know
where travis is going i'll let you have
in a second but as you said for the
accessibility the whole point of it is
for people with like you know if it's
hand issues whatever even my brother
doesn't really like enjoying controllers
because whether it's arthritis or
anything else like holding something
hurts his hand after an extended period
of time so if he's able to even manage
to do it that way but as you said
there's a give and take due to something
outside of the game and you're like
that's not the right way to do it so i'm
with you it's kind of shitty yeah i was
like
you may not agree on the full auto
that's a different piece but for the
accessibility piece they're going about
it the wrong way i fully agree with that
because my brother is literally one of
those who
plays on mouse and keyboard because
controllers hurt his hands like he's one
of those
i think it's a great change i think it's
awesome if they're looking out for
accessibility and they should continue
to do so
but it could be implemented in a way
that doesn't detract from the player
experience as well
and that would be a like a setting um i
still to this day think that fastball
should be a setting
say do i want my grenade to throw
further or shorter do i want my
character to sprint more to the right or
less to the right when i turn him
traction stuff like that should just be
settings my personal preference
and i feel like full autoing a gun if it
doesn't perform
if a lot of gun doesn't actually give
any benefit um where this implementation
wouldn't though would it
because like the product makes it fire
faster
this doesn't
from my understanding
yeah full auto
won't change the speed like full auto
mod increase the rpm because if it does
then i take back what i said
because the rpm is based on your your
reaction speed so this technically would
help with that like you can just hold
down the right trigger and you're
guaranteed to be shooting as fast as
possible or as normal you have to time
it
i mean and the same token people choose
to spray or people choose to top fire
their last words instead of full auto it
because it's an inherent advantage to
have more accuracy on your shot and know
where your shot is it still can be an
advantage like my thing is that if they
just made it a setting everyone would
enable it because it's like a clear
advantage and i think that like people
with disabilities understand that when
they're playing the game they're never
going to
be at parity with people who aren't
disabled like
they just want to be able to play the
game at a
in a in a way that like is acceptable
for them long term but like if you have
arthritis in your hand and you're you're
probably not going to be like a you know
competitive king no matter what because
you just have like handicaps that are
that are going to set you back but
there should at least be options in game
to do it i just think that
if there are options where
normal people could just use it to abuse
the game or to like gain advantages then
they should just make it something that
you have to choose in the in like you
should have to sacrifice the mod slot
basically um i i think trying to achieve
parity regardless is just not it's not
going to happen like no matter what
settings you do especially if all
players can gain access to those
settings i can like
i don't know it's like for the
accessibility piece i think if that's
their reasoning for it which is what
their explanation was previously i think
they're going about it the wrong way but
i also like for me like i'm not even a
skilled hand cannon user but i cannot
imagine like holding down my hand cannon
being beneficial in any way
to like ever feel like that's gonna be a
more accurate thing than taking the
small pause between to make those shots
count
scout rifle as well like to me i don't
think the full auto on a couple of those
that sidearms is probably one you
basically turn all sidearms into full
auto and you probably could do that
anyway since sidearms are basically
handguns as it is but like pulses scouts
and hand cannons is the other three i
don't see a lot of benefit or extra
accuracy that i'm gonna get out of that
and anytime you're going for a lot of
dps per se in a pve setting primaries
aren't really where you're gonna like
live and die on as it is so i don't see
why it has to be a mod personally
i don't know i just don't see that where
you're gonna get a lot of benefit like
oh i can just sit here and fire my hand
cannon over and over it's like oh and
the dude with the fall auto slightly
better i was like i don't see that being
maybe maybe not the hand cannon but
other other guns you could definitely
see it right like pulse rifles and stuff
that makes sense
to some extent on vigilance right
yeah personally
i know if there was a setting like that
i would not use it
um i know many other people who i also
believe would not use it i don't think
it's as much of a uh
as a benefit as um
i don't think it's as much of a benefit
um i honestly think it's
being able to fall out of a gun
versus being able to tap fire gun
especially when that does not change the
attributes of the gun like the rpm at
all
is a lot less about your gameplay
like the impact on the performance of
your gun and more about the impact on
your feel of the performance of the gun
it's a lot more personalized and
the reason why i feel like it should be
a setting
um is more so because given to all
players i genuinely do not think it
would benefit most
besides the people who choose to use it
as an accessibility option right i don't
think there is a tangible benefit to be
gained except for
i have a disability
i couldn't see myself using it i
definitely i i definitely understand
where you're coming from i just disagree
on the fundamentals of your argument
yeah i mean
i get all your points
to me it's like i know people who
like they really cherish when that perk
would come out when it goes
i i want to i do actually i do know
people who are like yo if falado was
like a big deal for the um i want to
actually take this a different direction
you guys went somewhere else which was
cool
um
i'm just thinking about like
everything prior now because if this is
a mod
like so now from now on full auto is out
of the perk pool
moving forward right and then for the
guns you have that had it
you kind of it's not like it's going to
be retroactive we're going to change out
full auto for the guys that had it and
give you
something else you know what i mean the
per the perk version increases the speed
at which the gun can be fired so it
still has a unique purpose
this is more like a like a poor a poor
man's uh
what i'm talking about just gives you
now i get what you're going i'm talking
about for those
who have legendary weapons currently
with full auto on it yep
the full auto mod is going to give
increase benefit
yeah but it already does it makes the
gun fire faster if it has all the uh
full auto what does it do
about like this this combo now this new
combo that's gonna be introduced right
it shouldn't shouldn't do anything
separate it shouldn't do anything right
but this is a mod right not a perk
correct
it's a mod right so
to me to me the mod isn't even that
like the mod the mod isn't that
important i i feel compared to like the
perks like the mod slot a lot of times
it's just like you know more accurate
when you're in the air it's like okay
yeah well i mean there's like major
minor spec and all that stuff but i
guess i'm just curious to see for the
people who have
legendary weapons with full auto on it
if they were gonna do anything you know
because i think it was i mean i think
they'll just they haven't said they're
going to specifically deprecate the mods
that are already there like what they
can't they've had perks on previous
weapons or they're like hey what was um
something and they had
they turned it off for every shotgun
they're not going to do that that's my
question they're not going to do that
for this they haven't at least said that
because i don't think
as travis said as a perk it adds 10 i
think it's 10 roughly or whatever if you
just hold it down and say and vigilance
wins the same way it does add a little
burst and you've earned the perk and
they've and it's not going to hurt
anything by being there i think this is
giving that accessibility ability option
for everything for legendaries not
exotics by the way though
i just wanted to see how they handle the
older stuff but would follow that was
all my question but yeah it's an
interesting discussion it clearly
seems
accessibility focused
i want to see how this plays out i just
don't know it's a very interesting thing
but i definitely hear where both of you
guys coming from you know reference to
it and you know for the hardcore i could
see them say hey this is no benefit to
me i'd rather put on you know something
else that's going to provide benefit and
i see for other people who like i do
know people that like yo i need that
full order bro i need it like i think
you know i do too and i i feel like if
it were an option people would
if it were just a
setting you could turn on i bet you lots
of people would do it maybe not people
in this group specifically but i i feel
like i know people who would and there's
there are probably ways to exploit that
too yeah i respect that take scarole as
far as i'm aware
though yeah possible no it doesn't say
no they literally only said hand cannons
sidearms
um pulses and
why am i forgiving the other one uh
scouts those the only four that it's
going to be an option for that's it
interesting so final piece as we get
into kind of the end of this topic
situation stuff um i wanted to
kind of read this stuff out but also as
we get towards the end of this i wanted
for you
uh swifty so i can just kind of plant
this in your head so you can think about
it i wanted to see as we are getting
into
um not as much 30th but witch queen like
what's your
wants hopes and dreams for stuff we
don't know about for that um so just
kind of plant that in the back your head
for now because that's where we're going
to kind of end up but i want to talk
about the stuff they mentioned for the
near future so they say annual
expansions are a good time for system
level changes since they get so much
more play test time over a longer
duration compared to a normal season
we don't like that the desire for exotic
catalyst is largely driven by the orbs
of power generation they provide and
have something in the works to let
players build around that limitation
they've mentioned this before hopefully
this works
uh weapon differentiation this is a
topic in all of itself because i don't
know what to read into this
if i have two void adaptive hand cannons
and is it adaptive like a 140 or 180 i
don't know if it matters two void hand
cannons of the same type go for that one
from a soros foundry and one from the
latest raid why do i care about one more
than the other the stats tend to be
fairly close you'll sometimes have a
little more range sometimes a little
less aim assist but
relatively close perk pools can be
different but there are only so many
perks and it's a stretch to say the perk
pool gives the weapon its identity
we've got some [ __ ] something shipping
on all new and reissued weapons in the
witch queen that addresses this issue
directly and we are working to expand
the same solution to all weapons that
drop in the future
i honestly wanted to take you guys
right like they could not have been more
here's some information but i'm gonna
tell you nothing that you need to know
but honestly like
what for you guys is the better question
what's gonna make you care about new
weapons because
i mean you can probably ask people
who've played for a while swift you've
probably got god knows how many hours in
this thing
after a while
a lot of moves between weapons
especially feel horizontal there's not a
lot of vertical growth in our weapons
it's just like here's this i have a i
think this is
oh go ahead yeah that's you guys get
where i'm going they're talking about
weapon crafting right
yeah i think i think this is them like
saying hey web and crafting is going to
let you do some stuff here but we don't
want to talk about it yet like that
that's kind of what i got from this but
yeah it was super vague in like a really
weird way of like yeah they didn't want
to be yeah
we've got something planned but we're
going to tell you literally nothing
about it and also yeah weapon crafting
is not going to use weapon parts
that's a whole different thing
swifty do you have any thoughts what
would
you probably have most of the gear that
you want between weapons and armor and
apparently you have that on your free
characters as well
what is going to make you
you have it twice what is going to make
you want new
what is going to make you want new
weapons in say a witch queen
so i treat my vault in my equipment a
little bit differently than a lot of
people
um
[Music]
i look at it as the best of each element
so if i have a gun let's say let's say
bose
um
bose for pve
i'm gonna have a bow for pve and if i'm
taking it into a grand master nightfall
per se i want a kinetic bow i want an
arc bow on a solar bow or void belt yep
and uh eventually when it's a thing if
it's thing i want a stasis spell right i
want a bow to cover my entire arsenal
now typically
the way that i look at weapons and roles
and what is desirable to me
um is that i will go through and i will
decide what the best
of a weapon and an element is and that
will be the only one that i grab so i
don't have a waking vigil and a nation
of beasts for example okay um
i don't have a bottom dollar and a
palindrome
uh for example though i do have an aclu
sink in but that's because i can make
war mud cells yeah different purpose
without very specific instances of
kind of separation
a lot of the guns to me feel bland
outside of an element
and so
for me
my journey with collecting good weapons
has been
are these perks interesting
what are the same weapons that come on
the same elements and then for the sake
of my vault size which is another issue
that can be talked
i'm with about
every time i'm sitting at 500 forever
but probably i'm not nearly as efficient
as you
so
i'm currently at about 374 looking at it
right now and this is because i hoard a
lot of armor uh armor is currently a lot
more valuable to me than weapons
um just because i'm a stat junkie i
enjoy stats i enjoy getting my triple
100s for example
kind of building out you know
uh it's it's very nice to me it's a
aspect of the game that i enjoy as far
as what makes a gun desirable new perks
obviously help but it's pretty defined
in a meta or in a state of game
what the best option is it's very
obvious when something falls behind why
would i use a dire promise
when i can use a time loss fatebringer
it is the same gun except one feels
better has explosive rounds and a better
perk pull right
and there are obviously going to be some
people who enjoy dire promises i know um
my friend zepper loves dire promise uh
he goes ham with that thing um and
there was a dire promise that was
recently sold monsieur
that was very very good
and a lot of people picked that up
but for me personally i don't see any
value in having a dire promise
because of time lost fatebringer and
that's how i widely view
a lot of my options
there are obviously like niche use case
examples
um
where like even though it's not the best
of the element i want to have it like
what i mentioned before
nikolas ain't canon it's void it's not
really the greatest i i actually rank it
above like it's one of the worst guns in
the game
i hate 180s so thank you
yeah
it's just like it's a 180 but then it
also just feels bad yeah
there is one reason and one reason alone
why i have this i call this in my vault
it is because i needed it to do solo
insights on this grammar
that is the only time i used it
and that initial quest for sleeper when
you had to use all the weapons and all
that yeah
just for the versatility just because i
can use uh yeah make warm on cells but
generally speaking
if there's a best version of a gun
element that is the one i'm going to
gravitate towards and i'm going to
dismantle other alternatives that's
literally what i do it's so funny
someone actually that's how i handle my
vault that's why i don't have too many
vault issues i'm going to look at what's
the efficient and
and and eliminate duplicates in in the
space
and it's all about the machete method
yeah yeah like it's like i'm not running
around with like like this example i'm
not running around with two or three
different void cannons provided the perk
pool are similar
and one just has better performance
stats or some type of extra appeal to it
that makes it the superior thing i'm i'm
literally gonna get rid of the other one
there's no need for me to hold on to it
and that that's how i make my business
decisions but i do find this interesting
that they
have i know that's my business that they
they they're talking they are alluding
to
this issue that i felt they've they've
they've long had and i'm dying to know
what this is i'm very curious to know
what this is to me is it going to be
more than just
oh the hacky
what is it the hockey whatever pole
shoots four or five shots versus
whatever
whatever that david y'all know what i
mean
whatever that you call it
versus the omalon you know i know like
some of them have intrinsic perks you
know with associate and i get it but i'm
very excited about this because i'm like
what could they be cooking up to make
these things different so this excites
me on some level i know
for those expectations right temperament
temper hard temper temperament way way
down all dudes just the witch queen
deceiving us yeah
savithun's making you think there's
weapon crafting but actually it's just
silver crafting
yeah uh cosmo has been has been uh
trapped for months
they did say they mentioned in the last
patch notes that were not done with
special ammo economy and pvp they have
further tweet coming for that should
help bring down the amount of special
ammo floating around
uh exotic primary weapons they say
already advanced ammo finder mods much
faster but we want them to feel better
in pvp pve content and adjusting all of
them to reach this goal i don't know
what that means for all primary exotics
but give me a reason to use the sunshot
and graviton lanes again and i'll
probably be happy
uh we're adjusting some exotics some
that consistently top the pvp usage
charts in an oppressive way some that
have their perts limp perks limited to a
good degree that's no longer warranted
we're looking at you chaperone
happy
sorry chaperone users it's time it's
been fun but it's
when they were going over the all the
debuffs and i saw that they were
debuffing slug shotguns but only in pve
i was secretly like oh my god thank god
they're not they didn't they're not onto
my grift yet
they they in fact have caught on
for six years i won't stop now
yeah here's the thing they need to give
chaperone
fine nerf it do whatever you gotta do
but give it give it a catalyst
give it a catalyst what's the catalyst
gonna do make it snipe from 50 meters or
something
maybe the catalyst could give it back
that whatever they're about to take away
from well then what's the point just go
earn what you just had that's that's a
cute way what is the point e great
question
what is the point to all of this
i want to swiftly just talk about his
hate for this i want to hear that i want
to hear this disgust
wanna hear my disgust yeah come on let's
get it am i being disgusted
i can't take your opinions of how
disgusted you are with anything in pvp
seriously because i just heard you talk
about the most disgusting toxicity of
leviathan's breath and gambling of all
nodes oh yeah
it's great you're just out here making
people cry in a mode that already makes
them want to cry just when it's working
normally it's working well people don't
want to play that and you're making it
worse for them this man
no i'm uh i i think you might have
caught the wrong drift from me i'm
entirely supportive of uh oh chaperone
yeah i think i thought
but i said it's a little bit ridiculous
i meant yeah chaperone is a little bit
ridiculous there you go oh before i got
you i got you yeah yeah yeah that's what
i thought yeah
yeah chaperone uh
bye
it's been a hell of a run
it's been a hell of a run it's been it's
been real it's been fun but i can't say
it's been real fun i just i find it
really funny that chaperone only became
good after shotguns range got neutered
like nobody used chaperone when a minors
could kill you at nine meters
i used it during the during the period
or
not at consistency i switched to fellow
hunters for a while but i used it for a
little bit we all we all fell
when shotgun uh shotgun range all of a
sudden goes down from like
nine to ten meters all the way down to
six seven meters uh all of a sudden
slugs are becoming a little bit uh
mm-hmm
a little bit better why would you why
would you choose why would you choose to
aim when you could just not aim and
start
question where does duality fall in
holidays duality is great i think
duality is second only to chaperone in
this slug discussion
uh duality um
there's a guy i assume you know him
called glow
yeah
g-l-e-a uxx or whatever yeah from encore
this guy is a
he's a
he's a creature with this thing man i
mean he is just
he pops off so hard i
i really like duality i think it's well
as the name suggests duality uh it has a
slug and a pellet uh the pellet is
pretty good i mean it's okay it's
mediocre it's right it's like fell
winters but it doesn't have the uh
the tighter uh spread
it's pretty subpar
um the slug though is also a weaker form
of chaperone yeah but the reason why i
like it so much is because of its
versatility you can use it in a lot more
situations it's an effectively a
a dual channeled gun
that is weaker in both aspects jack of
all trades masters
yeah yeah jack of all trades mastermind
and that's why i think it's perfectly
acceptable is because
it's it's definitively worse
but the utility that you can get out of
it is crazy good and that's why i love
the gun so much it just feels so
adaptive to different play styles and
environments that it's in
um it's just a really nice feeling gun
in my opinion
the last thing that i wanted to ask you
since i gave you a little time for it to
marinate
witch queen
comes in february we're going to get our
30th anniversary pop we're going to be
getting a few more swabs probably not
this meaty but talking about a couple
different things um
what are your
wants or
biggest hopes for
witch queen maybe stuff that's never
been mentioned maybe just a dream that
you've got
or just anything specific about it what
are your hopes for you know your quiet
non-social media time when you'll just
be focused on gaming and killing it
as far as witch queen goes um by the
time that witch queen is out i really
want them to extrapolate a little bit on
the future of destiny
and especially about the contentful
um i want there to be a lot more clear
definitions as to what we can expect to
go away what we can expect to come in in
return
um i
i'll be honest i really hate i really
really hate the content fault um it's
it's probably my least favorite feature
in destiny 2 and is a huge motivation
killer that just destroys it had a lack
of
feature my most favorite
not featured my most favorite knot
feature yeah
the sucker of joy the jellyfish that
comes along and just
stings the motivation yeah it sucks man
i hate it and
at the same time i obviously understand
it's a necessary evil but
part of me still just is holding out
hope that bungie will do their bungee
thing and find out a way to make it not
happen because
just knowing here's my thing right maybe
maybe uh people don't think the same way
as me as this
when i look at which queen
i do not think of the content we get in
two or three months i think of the
content we lose in two or three years
okay and that is heartbreaking and that
is a huge motivation killer to run that
and i
it is
the introduction of the content vault
has entirely reshaped the way i think
about the series
it has flipped me on my head
and given me an entirely new perspective
because if you go to world of warcraft
you can still play the the first raid
the molten
core yep i think one court to this day
i want to kill argos
one of the big bummers that i had is the
last week before beyond light i set out
to kill argos
and unfortunately i just didn't give
myself enough time i got kind of far i
got maybe halfway into the fight i got
like a good two breaks on him um i feel
like half health at my best attempt
if i was given more time i could have
gotten it and unfortunately i never got
to have that triumphant moment um
because
raids went away
um
but that's on me for poor time
management skills
i mean to a point it's on you but also
there's a lot of people that agree with
the fact and again it's this discussion
of like we had a business attorney on
here talking about like removing content
most other mmos don't tend to do this we
have the debate over like live service
bit mmos but as you said like
they're only
they have two reasons for this one is
space which is garbage because call of
duty exists because that's like 500 gig
but the other one is more of a fake
reason the other one yeah the other one
is debugging and that one to a point i
get but they could also truly just say
unless like and i guess if you could
literally like crash the game maybe
that's the thing that could have an
error report to come up but
like if stuff just is like too strong or
too weak in activities they don't need
to go check like sandbox balancing
for all of those places and it may be
things where it's just more crashes and
telesto breaks the world but if they're
worried about hey this is too strong or
too weak in here at some point they just
like have to let some of that stuff sit
there and just be content it's not gonna
give you pinnacles or anything like that
like
hell um
garden of salvation doesn't even what
doesn't even give you pinnacle um deep
stone crypt doesn't name you pinnacles
now so i was like i still feel like they
should just leave some of that stuff out
there and they don't need to go be like
does everything subclass void 3.0 or
whatever's coming does it still work in
here nobody it doesn't matter but to
give somebody the chance to go back as
you said and do the stuff you're gonna
do maybe you might be able to do it
easier with like particle deconstruction
but you'd still have a hell of a time
trying to solo that fight no matter what
it just might be a an asterisk on your
clear who knows but yeah
i mean but i'm but i'm with you it's
like
at some point because we got to talking
about the dungeon costing specific for
both like you know the deluxe edition
and then now you've got the 30th
anniversary
and there's this thing called shattered
shattered throne sitting out there is
the oldest dungeon
just i'm waiting when when did that
thing fall off like that one came part
of forsaken a dreaming city still
survived but when dreaming city goes is
that dungeon gone is the last wish gone
one of the coolest like one of the
coolest like story implemented raids the
story's gone for last switch which is
already bad
so no i'm
yeah i'm with you that i'm not a big fan
of this in the long term because you
said we get which queen now but when
does beyond light go away how will you
get stasis then
like what what are the ramifications of
the content vault before this like
10-year thing ends that is i agree on
that for sure yeah it's it's just it's
such a scary concept to think that the
game could evolve so much in three years
from now i think um
around the time i have no idea what
their plans are after lightfall i know
they said that they wanted to continue
the series oh the final shape
yeah finally final shape yeah uh i think
at the point of the final shape
they're gonna seriously have to
reconsider
making a destiny three jumps they have
to
they have to
like they have to the game is so broken
at that point
like see this game
the issue with destiny and the content
folder is that at a fundamental level
it's not sustainable and so they have to
take that and kind of take that in
stride like we're going to continue on
this path of sort of self-destruction
where to bring in new content we're
going to remove old content we're going
to remove fan favorite raids in order to
bring in new raids that's live service
games though
it's not necessary that's the difference
is it's not necessary and it's not a
fortnight concert like this is
again it's like fortnight you didn't pay
for the concert yeah that could go away
because you didn't pay for it you paid
for forsaken you paid for beyond like
you paid for these other pieces i don't
think
i don't think you'll be paying for it
for much longer and if if you are then
you shouldn't that's a separate argument
about their their model but right the
point is the game they're making doesn't
match their payment model but if it did
and then you would be like all right
this is a game as a service game i kind
of understand that everything that i'm
playing is kind of subject to getting
taken out but it's always so arbitrary
though like i i i it is very arbitrary
and just to be clear i don't i'm not
defending the system i also think it's a
really stupid system i'm just saying
that i i think that the game they want
to make is a live service game where
nothing is permanent and
they probably should do away with
selling people expansions in order to
make that make way more sense because it
doesn't right now but i think you guys
are probably
overestimating how much bungie tends to
stick with the
engines that they build like today
monday is the is the 20th anniversary of
halo
halo infinite is going to be the first
game that runs on a new engine since
halo came out
that's how long they keep engines
running forever so like i i think if you
think that they're just going to get rid
of the sandbox and do a destiny 3.
that's just not bungie's culture that
hasn't been their culture in the past
they're not even the ones making the new
engine for the halo infinite that's 343.
they were just ready to do as many games
as
as they wanted to with the with the old
engine the blame engine so i think that
i agree with this i agree with your
mindset i just think that um i believe
that what you're saying is their mindset
i just feel that there's enough evidence
to show
deterioration and and busting at the
seams
with with with especially since they've
gone on away from activision i feel
there's been way more
instances of just
i don't say like
shoddy
i mean mechanics it's just it's just
things
seem to be more busted as we've been
longer and going on and also
we're also seeing those extensions we're
also seeing the capacity of what we're
at with regards to how many perks can be
active on you at a specific time like
the game you know code per se actually
sticking together is one discussion but
when they literally flat say
we can't have an extra perk on said
weapon or something isn't going to work
they're already at their
literally they're bursting at the seams
with what the game is going to be able
to function and that's what worries me
yeah to me to me all the moves when i
hear dcv
it's just compensation like you you're
trying to overcompensate for something
you're trying to avoid the inevitable
and well you know it's fine i mean if if
that that's what they want to do but at
some point
it is it is curious when we get to final
shape
and then
the timing of the new
ip
yeah i want to see what happens they did
they did say they're they're going to
continue with destiny too
right right
no they did they did they absolutely did
i'm just i'm very curious
to see you know how this game continues
to age at that stage of degeneration i
mean unfortunately like world of
warcraft has gone on for so long it's
aged okay but i mean they've done like
cosmetic updates too but i was like can
you imagine them putting like ray
tracing in this game it would break it
just absolutely break it now ray tracing
is a cute feature right now because it's
not that strong don't get me started on
rage i know it's like that's kind of a
joke but also it's like
when are you gonna get to a point where
this is truly just a next-gen game and
when is it finally gonna be an excuse
that a ps4 is no longer holding back
destiny
when you release the next like saga what
comes after the final show you have to
go to the lowest common denominator
every single one that's why i know and
this one's like which which hinders game
design yeah at the end of the day you
when you continue to have to expand this
cross-platform development cycle with
more and more additive uh consoles and
pc iterations
you hinder game design you you cannot
get to the scope of what you truly want
to do when we're talking about weapon
perks and even simple things and at some
point the rubber will hit the road it's
just i just yeah you get i i will say
that i think people
over blow this point a lot in in game
development like do old consoles hold
back new games
game design game design yes kind of
the actual thing that holds back
new game design is the fact that the
consumer isn't ready to make the leap
yet if the consumer has an old console
and nobody's upgrading to the new one or
they have old pcs
the the new tech is just too expensive
then the thing that's actually holding
you back has nothing to do with the
console that's adoption
yeah that's adoption right you can make
the same argument for pcs like nobody
has a 30 90 right now and if they
started making stuff with 3090s the
problem wouldn't be that the tech isn't
there the problem would be that the
consumer isn't caught up yet of course
so i i think the uh
like
to me it's more like you can't you can
make the most crazy game but if only
five yeah that small percentage yeah
yeah who cares you know like
it's that was sort of the problem with
half-life alex right it's a great game
that nobody was able to play
my point is three years from now my
point is three years from now
that is a point where you have to make a
ps5 xbox series x game only
it's out of destiny 2's 10-year saga
that has to be a next-gen console
exclusive game and if it's not it's like
then
then it's like your hopes of anything
escalating to something fun because like
i always talk to you guys about armor
3.0 i've talked to you office on like so
long about that but i was like my hopes
for that are so far away when they talk
about perks on weapons breaking like
perks on weapons breaking the game makes
me think like armor 3.0 cooler perks
like set bonuses things those don't even
seem like they're a possible option
because a weapon perk breaks it right
now i'm like and if that's an issue then
you tell me this is as much fun as i'm
going to have is what we got right now
that's the problem for me
so if do you got any thoughts on this
insanity by the way
uh so destiny's already done this um
back when taken king uh when they
kind of spread their wings and lost the
old gen consoles i believe correct me if
i'm wrong
that was stated they did was hardware
limitations and not being able to
support i remember bad like the the
worst it might have been rise of iron
though was it was it wrong
yeah i thought they held on longer
rise of iron might have been yeah
one of the two one of the two point
being i i could be wrong about this
right but i am fairly certain the point
that i remember them bringing up as to
why they ditched the consoles
was because
of the hardware limitations that
catering to these like nine-year-old
consoles was was doing for them we're
not nine years old but close
obviously it gets to a point where you
do have to
kind of make the step up but um like i
i'm not i'm not arguing that they that
they don't have to do it i think
probably the series x and the ps5 are
already hardware limitations to them
because game designers are they're
always dreaming bigger right the issue
is that you have to work around what the
consumer's ready for like
it's it's like with cell phones right
people who make video games for cell
phones they look at they don't look at
only the most recent cell phone well we
need to design for that they look at
where all the where the players are yeah
the play base how many iphone 7s are
people still using and then they build
it around
serving the most people while not
holding back the game it's always a
compromise yeah but i will say i think
like in defense if they did it if they
did it today
there would only be us yes yeah of
course they can't do it now yeah we we
completely completely
yeah and that's kind of the thing is
like
right now yeah that's too soon but also
like next year they're starting to see
more and more games that are next gen
only that's starting next year and
that's the same year as witch queen and
we have two more years of this of this
d2 limping beyond that
and that's kind of the point is like if
you get to two more 2024
is final shape theoretically if i don't
think it'll make it that far i i think i
think the the xbox one and ps4 are gone
like by i mean you'll have ps4 pros
you'll have ps4 pro or ps5 pros and
maybe like i've already heard rumors
about like ps5 pros yeah xbox series x2s
whatever they're called who knows their
naming scheme is going to make me have a
headache they're naming their naming
scheme is going to make me have a
headache but that's fine
but like that potentially could be 2023.
so then you have something that's a ps5
pro
still having to and then theoretically
in 2024 2025 your stuff that's like
you're telling me i can't even use a ps5
to say like this is the bar at that
point
um no that's just like post final shape
it has to be
it has to get a whole lot of freshness
to it and chances because otherwise
i don't think something post final shape
is going to be much worth it at that
point you're going to be seeing some
amazing stuff in the next few years and
if destiny is going to be held back that
far i just don't think it would work and
we are at about three hours we probably
got to start wrapping it up
we definitely go but there's a good
discussion i mean love the tangent yeah
it was a great it's actually a great
tangent great tangent
but no i definitely hate what travis is
saying in reference to uh it always
going to go down to the decision is
always going to be based on the
economics of the populace
and where they are that part is
absolutely right that's because yeah
it's stupid for them to say yo
right now
series x only playstation 5 only there's
not enough in the wild to justify it but
when it eventually gets there like um
you know what what's called swifty was
talking about they would whether it
would be taking kicking rise vine there
was that internal cutoff where the
majority of the generation was at that
level and it made no sense left to
support cut bait now make game design a
little better we're not constrained we
don't have to keep waking making you
know this lowest common denominator
thing and that's it but great discussion
boys yeah thank you this was a long one
swifty you got anything else you want to
add before we do the outro wrap up
uh no not particularly it was a really
good conversation we went through a lot
of points and i'm like i'm really glad i
came it was a really nice uh really nice
time
thank you guys for joining us happy
retirement
happy retirement
finally i guess i should be getting a
gold watch
i should speak on this let's get it to
speak on this
i do i did send the link to a couple of
my friends and they were
wondering about some clarifications so
here's my situation
i've never really been a content creator
uh i haven't really streamed on twitch
in a couple months
youtube i mean i had a short little
stint with anthem but we all know who
that one
shout out to destiny
destiny
there was one day when i launched an
anthem video on like a farming guide and
then i went to bed
and i forgot that i left my discord
server in the description of it and when
i woke up i didn't even tell people to
do this people were using the vcs in my
destiny discord server as like anthem
farming session like loot grabs and [ __ ]
so i woke up and i just made a bunch of
categories for for anthem it just blew
up and it was really fun but
it's uh side tracking uh youtube kind of
short-lived um twitch obviously kind of
short-lived so i really did enjoy
getting to stream almost all of the 1000
grand masters i did while helping people
through gm's it's a great time
um but
so i think it's a little bit of a time
for a change uh school
accuplacers recently meeting with a
guidance counselor on uh wednesday i'm
getting hooked up to college
and at the moment my life kind of
revolves around an exe file on my
computer and end up on my phone not
being destiny 2 and twitter um so i've
decided to kind of make the step in my
life
where i kind of clowned around in high
school middle school a lot
i was never really an a plus guy i was
kind of a ds get degrees kind of okay
okay
i've had a little bit of a change in
tone recently and um decided that i'm
going to
distance myself from the internet
distance myself from uh from twitter
kind of delete some of my social medias
okay um and so i'll still be playing
destiny
my involvement in this community
uh is definitely gonna stop here for the
meanwhile but i really appreciate
uh the times that i had here i was able
to do a lot of incredible things and i
don't regret
kind of this chapter of my life
whatsoever and uh thank you especially
to bontas cognito and travis for
inviting me here uh it is
incredibly fitting that kind of my last
words as a member of this community is
on the last word podcast i just find
that
so
so phenomenal that i got to have this
moment in like the greatest
the greatest setting possible it's such
a great coincidence
uh i wasn't even sold on the idea of
kind of
shipping and quitting and just going to
college uh
when i agreed to this so i was gonna do
this regardless but uh just having
everything come up recently my discord
getting hacked i'm talking to some other
friends
kind of taking a step back uh made me
realize i think it's time for change and
uh
i think
well symbolically these are my last
words
that's that's pretty much all i wanted
to say
samantha you rather that's the way to
end the show
can't end it any better you was about to
say something oh i was just gonna say it
was an absolute pleasure having on you
on for kind of your social destiny swan
song uh a little bittersweet way to end
the show but yeah it's like you've been
in the community the help that you've
done and just you know it's like i've
always seen you on twitter i think it
was even you i worked with on a graphics
card to get to somebody was that you
right that i did that through
uh you gave me my series x
oh that was it yeah okay
yeah i knew i knew i hadn't worked with
you
yep
yeah i had a bundle that i was able to
like basically get my hands on i was
like all right who wants this thing it
costs cause where's my series
[Music]
it was an absolute pleasure i know
travis enjoyed you being on because
you hit a lot of the right notes for him
uh cognito enjoyed you being here as
well definitely hit some hopes and
honestly
i'm just happy to have you but as you
said yeah literally we're gonna we're
gonna let you have the last word when we
get to the final outro and we're gonna
stay silent for this one just for a rare
change because it truly will be your
kind of swifty last word yeah so but
before we go um normally we'd let you
have your socials but those won't exist
tomorrow so
quick travis and cognito if you guys
want to uh do anything for an outro real
quick for you guys
not just uh again tremendous to have
swifty on he's
huge in the community you know much
respect i love what
the plan is you know what i mean and
life and whatever his next journey is
and game development
or well is taking his talents to south
beach or whatever he he plans on doing
which i'm excited for but now salute
salute like a great discussion love your
analytical approach to to gaming and
destiny and we do it we three hours flew
in a sense because we had some great
great discussions brother and awesome
yeah absolute pleasure absolutely flint
to having last word and yeah i know what
y'all can find me i hate we got to get
into all that
but this is your moment bro this is this
is you so salute to you brother and uh
i'm looking forward to you doing great
things yeah travis anything else you
want to add same here
yeah same here i won't promote my stuff
today because i think everybody knows
where to find me but uh uh it was great
meeting you good luck in your next
endeavors um
and you will not be forgotten swiftly
i like that i like that no no that put a
destiny gun and your tag into a pond so
nice that was nice normally as we outro
the show um basically i'll just say like
the episode number and i will say it has
been and we all try and say last word
together when we do that this time these
two are killing me so if you guys are
watching youtube right now or watching
the video and you wonder why these are
holding up their fingers in these weird
little like handgun like finger guns
some caddies
um basically what it was is one of like
my internet is hit or miss every so
often and every blue moon for discord
i'm just gonna get like stuck in a
position for whatever reason i got stuck
just like this so whatever like hand
gesture i was doing was just like this
and i was just stuck here and they were
just looking at me like this for so long
and they just can't get over it so
that's what that is
so if you know you know and mostly they
know because i don't even think stream
saw that one but
everybody in stream you guys have been
amazing um all of
all of you guys in chat thank you for an
awesome episode and swifty thank you for
sharing what is a kind of a bittersweet
but uh very fitting episode so thank you
for joining us around the campfire
episode number
173 if i can remember correctly november
11th
and for this episode
it has been
the last word